foreign
I'm gonna pass some around pleasure to
sure
got um printouts too pretty for the
well good morning everybody
welcome to environment and agriculture
the house committee
um my name is representative Judy Aaron
and I will be your chair for the next
two years hopefully
[Laughter]
um
I'm I hope everybody got the email that
I sent out and I don't know if you had a
chance to
look at the orientation package that I
sent but I also had printed copies made
I don't if you've printed them out
that's fine
so we'll start off with just some basic
introductions and I'll let everybody get
in get seated
okay
so as I said uh I'm Judy air
representative Judy Aaron I
represents Sullivan County District 4
which are the towns of Acworth Goshen
Langdon lemster and Washington most
nobody most people don't even know where
Acworth is
it's a town of 850 people very small
so I'd like to make some introductions
of uh our our leadership team here which
is uh my vice chair Jim Creighton Jim
why don't you say a few words about
yourself
uh thank you madam chair
I'm Jim Creighton from antrum this is my
second term
uh my first term was in rrd and I've
been accused of abandoning a ship but
I'm thrilled to be here in environmental
and agriculture
I'm a retired army colonel 30 years
um and uh lives in Antrim now for about
eight years and uh on ski patrol and
love being in New Hampshire that's it
thank you and to my left here is
representative comtwa who will be our
Clerk
hi um representative comtwa I'm from
Barnstead New Hampshire this is my
fourth term in the enan uh
on this committee I've been involved
with this committee before that since
about 2012.
um so have been coming to these meetings
for quite some time
thank you representative and then we
have our ranking member representative
Bixby hi representative Peter Bixby
um and uh this is going to be my sixth
term on this committee and so I started
here in 2012. uh and uh so I'm the
institutional knowledge here
um and I'm from Dover New Hampshire and
uh
and do a fair amount of Homestead
orcharding and gardening and have a few
chickens uh and
um have uh you know we can you know go
into more details later but uh that uh
thanks
I have some chickens too I'm glad to
save some money on eggs these days and
then our Deputy ranking member is a
representative Murray hi thank you my
name is representative Murray I am at
third term here in environment and
agriculture I represent the towns of
Amherst and Milford I live in Amherst
and I am extremely excited to see
familiar faces and new faces so welcome
thank you
thank you so I would also like to go
around the rest of the room here and
starting with representative Davis
please tell us a little bit about
yourself maybe something fun that people
should know about you
good morning representative Arnold Davis
I'm from Co-op District 2.
this is my second term here I I like
this committee because it's pretty
bipartisan everybody gets along and that
really drew me to this committee uh
is
something fun I'm not sure but uh
my my district they had it goes
Pittsburgh Clarksville Errol Milan Stark
all the unincorporated towns in Dumber
so there's so few people they had to
give me half a cross county to make my
uh but also the town of Dumber so that
would make me the Dumber rep yeah
uh my name is Sherry dutzy I represent
Nashua Ward 3. this is my third term on
environment and agriculture
um
and there's really not much else to say
I I'm on the I chair of the Nashua
Conservation Commission I like to garden
and I'm continuously a continuous
learner of the French language so that's
hi everybody
I'm representative smart and I represent
um Belknap District 2. I come from
Meredith and
my husband and I have a small farm we
we raise our own food and help Supply
the neighborhood also
as far as anything fun I
there's nothing fun about me I don't
think I can't think of anything so I
I'm representative Molly Howard there's
another representative Howard named
Heath so I'll give you my first name I
am from Hillsboro I represent
Hillsborough District 31 I live in
Hancock and uh my district also uh
includes Greenfield
um and uh I am a burgeoning farmer I
also have chickens and uh I have every
year I put in a new um
garden bed and I'm up to about a quarter
of an acre now and my neighbor across
the road has a bad back and just gave me
another quarter of an acre so I'll be um
doing a lot of gardening this year
foreign
hi my name is representative Potenza I'm
in Stratford District 19 which is all of
Rochester except for Ward 5.
um
this is new for me I didn't pick this so
I'm just put on here so I'm going to
embrace it and uh I do care about the
environment deeply especially about
good morning everybody I'm
representative Robin vote I am from
Rockingham district 21 which is
Portsmouth Ward one and Newington
this is my first term so I'm very
excited and uh something fun that I like
to do I am an avid mid-century modern
furniture Hunter so I like to look for
Unique pieces of furniture in my free
time
good morning uh my name is uh Nick
germanna I am from Keene represent uh
district one uh in Keene I'm also
professor of History German history at
Keene State College and I don't bring
any particular set of skills to this
committee or experience but one of the
reasons why I wanted to be on the
committee is because it's an area I want
to learn a lot about I have a great
interest in and and uh and I want to do
what I can to to help out
um I guess in terms of interesting
things I just recently completed my
third book which is a biography of the
philosopher Emmanuel Kant so when it
when it all when it comes out I will
make sure to use committee time to
advertise uh its availability so thank
you
I'm Allison Now by represent stratum
over in the Seacoast and
I'm excited to be on this committee I am
on my town select board and I've been on
the Conservation Commission for about 15
years and I'm also the executive
director of The Great Bay stewards which
is the friends group to the Great Bay
National estuarian research reserve
and I once did research work at the
international potato Institute in Peru
so I'm available for all per potato
related legislative
um so nice to meet you all
I'm representative Linda Haskins and of
Irish ancestry so I'll get back to you
on the potato situation I live in a 200
year old factory building that's been
converted converted into condos no
thank you madam chair uh my name is Jake
brullard I represent Rockingham one I'm
from Nottingham
my background is environmental health
and safety
uh I enjoy the outdoors and I'm excited
to be uh part of this committee and
working alongside of all of you thank
you
good morning my name is
um Catherine zafakitis please don't call
me representative because of all the
things I am the most proud of is that
I'm a nurse and nurses by practice
always go by their first name
so please don't call me representative
I've been on this committee for three
terms this is my fourth I'm an organic
Gardener I put up my food every year
canning wise and um
I am a quilter and a quilt designer and
hi my name is Kathy Kenny District 13 in
Hudson
um I have egg laying chickens I also
raise meat chickens and I have vegetable
garden and and flower gardens I've been
a member of Audubon for many years and
in office for the Nashua chapter
I also managed a veterinary hospital for
21 years
I'm very
um
uh interested in the agricultural aspect
thank you everybody what a wonderful
collection of great backgrounds and
different interests
um it's it's wonderful uh representative
Bixby yeah so um one the your potato
work makes me think about uh one thing
that came through our committee uh back
in 2000 I think it was actually might
have been my first term in 2012 which
was a a fourth grade bill
um and uh what for those who people who
are new
fourth graders always
almost all fourth graders in public
schools in New Hampshire come to tour
the state house and they part of their
curriculum is learning about state
government and some fourth grade classes
put together bills and that they think
would be good and they contact their uh
their representative and the
representative will put it in for them
so
um this was a bill on that uh
representative O'Connor from Derry put
in at the request of the
um the fourth graders in his town and it
was a bill to make the potato the state
wonderful
when did that happen
uh I think it was 2012. yeah
okay or actually 2013 it would have been
2013 I think so it was the the session
that started in December of 2012 so uh
yeah
I believe also that the first potatoes
were planted in Derry I believe that was
one of the reasons that the Derry school
group um did that I'm not mistaken
that's correct and also but at that
point it was called nut field oh cool
okay
so I'm going to um go through this
booklet a little bit but I see that Arc
I'm going to skip ahead for just a
second
um I see that our committee researcher
is here and I know she's going to be
between us and the Commerce Committee
this morning so I'm going to introduce
Kristen Grant who is our committee
researcher
and um
if you skipped if you look on page seven
of our handout it talks about what the
committee researcher does Kristen would
you come up and just introduce yourself
and tell a little bit about yourself and
also what what you will be doing for our
committee
yep
seeing as you're here I figured I'd get
it it's a great opportunity take
advantage of that to speak when I
usually get to hide in the back
um my name is Kristen Grant I'm I grew
up in New Hampshire from Exeter I went
to UNH and then went to law school
somewhere else but
um came back after about four years in
Massachusetts but
um so I've lived here almost all my life
and um
so now I'm here and as a committee
researcher
we do a lot of things but one of the
main things is to you know look into
any questions that I get from chair
Aaron who usually goes through her
because I'm working on on behalf of the
committee
and I will research you know legislative
history how many times have we done this
before and what happened or you know
what you know it's not for me to
interpret but to just present to you
this did it and that didn't
um or what other states are doing with a
given topic or you know even you know
what what have you in order for you guys
to make your considerations on the bills
that are in front of you so if you need
anything I mean you can always visit us
on the fourth floor but if you know take
officially the requests generally go
through the chair maybe even the vice
chair maybe the clerk you know you guys
can work that out for yourselves but um
that's just to distinguish us from you
know other researchers who you know you
might go to before you put in a bill or
something like that
um to do research for you individually
thank you anybody have any questions for
Kristen
thank you madam chair
just an additional point on that um I
just wanted to clarify that in the event
that you need additional research for
something else you're working on
legislatively that goes through OLS so
as a personal legislative matter correct
and the I don't know that it's oh well
is it OLS it is OLS okay I think it is
all right right right okay thank you yep
yep
I think that's yeah that's one of the
key distinctions is this is It's not
that everybody on the committee has to
want to know whatever it is I'm
researching but
um you know
so if we will generally be distributed
you know if if the chair chooses so if
we're working on a bill we've had a
committed hearing and we're doing a work
session or something and and any of you
have a specific question that you would
like to have researched like say for
instance what other what others what are
other states doing with regard to
um micro Enterprise home kitchen
operations you can pose a question to me
and then I would get in touch with
Kristen
representative Bixby yeah so an actual
example was
um I was
um representative Compton and I were on
a uh study committee last fall looking
at soil conditioners and uh I asked uh
Ms Grant to
um look into what the fee structures in
neighboring states were for uh for
fertilizers and other soil amendments
and she provided a very thorough list
with some good commentaries so thank you
I was going to say I hope it was useful
hahaha
okay
does anybody have any questions
okay seeing none thank you very much
enjoy uh the rest of our meeting going
okay so I'll just um uh going through
some uh
uh the ground rules of how our committee
operates or
uh
our start times are going to be in
general at nine o'clock on Tuesdays
we are sharing this room with two other
committees one is um
Municipal and County government and the
I forget
uh oh Legend legislative Administration
um anyway so if we are I will let you
guys know uh when and it will be in the
calendar as well when our meetings will
be
um I I know that we have a couple of
early bills coming up we have uh three
um and we'll be looking at scheduling HB
128 it does every everybody has the um
the grid that has all the bills so far
we have 16 bills in this committee
and we have HB 128
that is due out February 16th
we have HB 300 and HB 326 which is also
due out February 16th so those are early
bills we'll need to make a decision a
recommendation from this committee uh
regarding those three
so I'll be working with uh Ollie you
folks here to figure out when to
so um
regarding absences
um
I would like you to please let me know
and also let
um Peter representative Bixby know uh
when you will be unable to attend a
meeting whether it be hearings or
executive session just so that I know
and can anticipate when you will be
absent
today I know
um representative Morse is not with us
because there's an illness
and representative verville is out of
state for business
um I don't know I haven't heard anything
from representative coulon so I don't
know
um
so
expecially for executive session when we
are voting on uh the disposition of any
particular bill
we need to know whether you will be
present or not and um
uh the
uh
for the Republicans they would let me
know the Democrats would let
representative Bixby know that way you
can arrange a substitute to come and
vote on the bill representative Bixby
yeah just a little more detail detail on
that uh if uh you let
um one of us know soon enough uh within
so that we can give 24 hours notice then
we can get a substitute for you uh on
you know with the from the appropriate
party and but if uh if that notice comes
to us too late then we can't get a
substitute which means that there would
be
um a
there there wouldn't be a vote there
would be one vote missing from the
committee on that so um it's it's good
for practical reasons to make sure you
let us know uh sufficiently in advance
thank you madam chair uh I would assume
in terms of notifications similar would
apply to if we're not able to be here at
the starting time you know for example I
have to drop my son off at school before
I come over and I'm usually not able to
get here until about 9 45 so I intend to
be here on those days but you know if
I'm missing 45 minutes of the of the
hearing that's okay as long as I know
you're going to be here it's fine
okay and with regards to email and I did
send out an email to everybody regarding
this meeting to the environment
agriculture
email list
so I hope that
the email that is tied to that list is
um
and you
can utilize a personal email address a
account but you have to remember that
any email account that you use for
legislative activity will be subject to
the Freedom of Information Act
now for me I have separate emails one
I'm dressing decorum please dress prep
professionally when attending our
committee meetings
our hearings of course we will be uh
live streamed so we want to look
professional and uh business attire is
recommended
food coffee and lunch breaks
no food or drinks other than water
should be consumed while the public is
present or viewing you remotely
um exceptions are medical issues and we
can discuss that offline
and uh
I will try very hard to make sure that
we have enough breaks and that we have a
lunch period today our Lunch Period will
be from 12 to 1. if we get done going
through this a little bit earlier we can
leave earlier that's fine
yes
yeah um if you're going to drink some
water please don't leave it on the
desktop here
um there are like little places
underneath the table you can put them
but it's just um it's a distraction and
we want to make sure that uh everybody's
talking about distractions
um use of electronic devices
now of course we are okay to have our
laptops if we need our laptops to take
notes
and perform any kind of necessary
committee work
but you have to remember that when we
have our public hearings our attention
should be to the speakers and what they
have to say
we want to be very respectful with our
attention to our speakers and to each
other
we want to make sure that our any kind
of ringers on our phones are muted
so as not to be distracting if we get a
phone call an incoming phone call
Representative thank you madam chair and
in the past there has been a Five Dollar
Fine uh for any phone that rings
okay
committee room drawers I'm going to have
representative Murray explain about our
committee room drawers
thank you madam chair so our committee
room has an office just outside so um
our assistant is Heather goalie and then
just across the hallway is our committee
room where those drawers are your name
is on them those are for you to keep
your items in whether it's items that
you need for the day or you want
something to carry over if you want
snack bars or whatever they can go in
there and am I also talking sort of
about okay and in addition we are asking
um this term that this is your file
where all of the bills that are given to
you from Heather will sit and and this
is your one shot this is your copy that
you will receive for the bill and those
go in there so please don't take these
home with you and then forget and on
committee day if they come back and you
don't have them and you want to refer to
a certain line in a bill it's
problematic unless you print out your
own copy and bring it back and forth but
these are those copies and those can be
left in your drawers as well yes
the the folder as well can no the folder
is is yes it sits at your table yes and
Heather collects it and then that's
correct some new stuff comes out that's
correct
so the folder is basically how they will
collect it after each session and if
there's new stuff to be handed out then
it will come again come back again so
this is it's sort of the uh thank you
the Pony Express or something for those
pills but yeah so this this group of
things that you have is can be kept in
that drawer
now the uh on hearing days we will have
copies of the bills on the table at the
side there
however those bills those copies are
meant for the public who are in the
people who are attending uh the hearing
they're not really meant for you to say
oh well you know I'll just grab a copy
because uh I took mine out of my folder
so
please make sure that you keep your your
information that you're going to need in
your bill file folder and that your bill
file folder stays in your committee
drawer here
representative quantois thank you madam
chair I think the other important thing
is if you have valuables and you want to
lock them away for the day the drawers
do have keys but make sure you do not
okay anybody have any questions so far
nope okay
so we'll go on to emergency procedures
for our committee rooms
and I mean it will be my responsibility
to just direct everyone from the
committee room
um of the emergency procedures in event
of an emergency situation
if we have to evacuate the building we
will hear an alarm
and we will exit the building
we have the the north south and west
staircases
using the West staircase must exit to
the green to Green Street which is out
um we would not stay in the lob garage
and under no circumstances in an
emergency should we be using the
elevators
if we have to shelter in place we would
be going to room 207 and 307 as
designated areas to wait for assistance
um or for those who cannot for some
members are to evacuate to a determined
place where the chair shall take head
count and ensure all members have exited
the building where has our collection
Point normally been in the past
uh
we haven't actually I I don't remember
do you remember uh so uh and it's not
something we ever practiced and and we
never had an emergency in my in the time
that I was here
um but
um
I believe
since we exited to Green Street then uh
which is this one here right right yes
so uh then we should
um meet on on the opposite side of Green
Street roughly opposite the parking
garage yeah I believe that that's
actually I believe that that was the
place if I recall now yeah that was
um access to the building shall be
authorized by the Concord fire
department personnel and communicated
via Protective Services Chief in order
to re-enter the building
in case of a medical emergency we would
um
and we would have to report what
happened the victim's name and condition
we have a AED devices located in the lob
Lobby in case we need them
um
in case of something happening in the
room here of course we would want to
and not move the victim so and so forth
I'll let you read through this if you
have any questions
um in in case of any kind of disturbance
in our meetings
we have a member that would
discreetly get help for us or or to
alert
um our protective services staff to come
and
make sure that the situation doesn't get
we have numbers listed here for
emergency After Hours the nurse's office
the end seat by the door is the
committee's emergency person
and basically it's like sitting in the
emergency room of the airplane
and our designated person is
for fire alarm exits we have a chart on
the wall
of the committee room that shows where
the exits are if you want to check that
out later on
so let's talk more about the the
committee our committee and what our
charge is and how we operate and
what our Protocols are
according to rule 31f
it is the duty of the committee on
environment and agriculture to consider
all matters concerning Agricultural and
farm problems of the state physical land
use including current use
the various agricultural organizations
the protection of the state's
environment from forms of pollution
other than air or water pollution waste
management issues and such other matters
as may be referred to it
so that's our charge
and you will see by the collection of
bills that we've received so far
in terms of partisan balance
I'm thrilled and proud that this
committee has always been run as a
nonpartisan committee
and I expect it to remain that way
we work together
we leave our party Federal party
National Party whatever party out at the
door and we work together
uh to solve these problems in the forms
of these bills that come to us
would you like to say a few words about
that representative Bixby
sure uh this so
um one of the things I've always valued
about this committee is that we are we
work in a non-partisan way uh almost all
the time there have been minor
exceptions once in a while but we are
have been very good about working in a
nonpartisan way and working together as
colleagues and
um that's pretty much been the way it's
been since even before I was here and
um I think that one of the things one of
the Hallmarks of that is that uh last
term uh we with I think
two or three exceptions
all of our bills were on the consent
calendar
and uh and one of those that was was on
the consent calendar was wasn't on the
consent calendar was not on it simply
because it involved a large money amount
and it had been a unanimous or close to
unanimous vote uh and the way we do that
is not by just saying oh well we'll just
agree on everything it's we do the hard
work of figuring out how to get bills
that aren't ready to go uh into a
condition where we can all agree that
they are the best bills that we can get
out of committee and
sometimes that takes multiple passes and
it takes you know it takes some hard
work there are some bills where we'll
look at the bill and we'll say well you
know this obviously doesn't fit the the
needs or uh benefits of the State of New
Hampshire and we'll just say no that's
not something that's going very far very
fast and there are some that we can look
at and say you know that is you know
obviously uh an important nuts and bolts
thing that we can just say good do it
but there are some bills where there are
complicated issues and we work hard on
trying to understand them and uh the
fact that there are 20 of us means we
have 20 different perspectives that we
can look at this from and uh things that
go through the process of discussion
with within the committee really get a
better
um hearing and a better analysis because
there are so many of us with different
perspectives
and um so
uh let's you know stick with that idea
that you know it we are here doing the
nonpartisan work of this committee
partisan stuff stays outside the door
and
um and let's you know work you know well
thank you do you have anything to add
representative
thank you madam chair I think it's
important to note that this committee
deals with policy I think that's an
important distinguish uh distinguish
between some of the other committees but
we deal strictly with policy regarding
thank you
so some of the typical Bill topics we
will have
to do with I'm not going to I'm not
going to say current use I haven't seen
a current use Bill and um since I've
been here
and this is my third term on this
committee
solid waste recycling landfills product
of stewardship agricultural support and
promotion
Federal food safety modernization act
Farm stands pesticides Animal Welfare
both farm and household so those are the
kinds of things that we're going to see
come before us
now earlier I mentioned early Bills
going to Second committee we had three
of those
sometimes we have bills that need to be
addressed quickly because they have to
go to another committee like Finance
and those bills get priority treatment
in order to get them in and out of our
committee quickly
we also have subcommittees
and the committee a subcommittee is just
a subset of this committee
and they further work on if we have a
bill that needs a little bit more
work and we don't have the time as a
full committee to to discuss it
we put that out to one of our four
subcommittees
we have an environmental policy commit
subcommittee
an agricultural policy and current use
committee subcommittee animal protection
and Licensing subcommittee and a solid
waste subcommittee I have some sign up
sheets here
I had asked you to think about
um
what subcommittee you'd like to be
working on
and so I'm going to pass this around and
if you'd like to put your name on it on
whichever subcommittee you'd like please
do that and I will collect that at the
representative Bixby could you explain a
little bit about the subcommittees and
and what goes in those sure
um
so
the Environmental Policy subcommittee uh
deals with
environmental policy that primarily
um is land-based uh so that would have
to do with uh one one common uh sort of
Bill that would fall under that would be
bills having to do with pesticides uh
bills having to do with
um
liking on other sort of uh do you
remember any other Environmental Policy
type bills that okay oh uh actually
there was we had a bill that had last
term that had to do with uh invasive
Upland invasive species that's something
that would fall into the Environmental
Policy subcommittee
um agricultural policy and current use
Uh current use almost I think I've seen
one current use Bill since I've been
here uh and that's looking at the
current the way the current use tax is
structured uh we probably won't see that
and agriculture policy we will certainly
see a number of those bills that could
be range from uh things having to do
with the definition of Agriculture and
agrotourism it could have to do with
um
Farms things having to do with Farm
stands things having to do with
homestead food production things having
to do with
um different regulations in the
Department of Agriculture having that
have to do with Agriculture
I have I have a couple bills coming in
based on that
um and uh
uh and yeah and then you know one can
sort of you know imagine there are
there's a there's a large range of
things that could fall under
agricultural policy uh animal protection
um
one thing that we've done a fair amount
with is looking at uh how animal cruelty
investigations are dealt with and uh how
the balance between is is struck between
the rights of the animals and the rights
of the owners and uh and how that and
um offshoots of that having to do with
how do we make sure that our disease
protection protocols in the state are
well founded but are reasonable
um and
uh
and things like you know if there were a
bill having to do with the cost of a dog
license it would it would go to that
subcommittee or
um
and uh then Solid Waste uh is things
like recycling landfill regulation
um and composting and uh ways of
reducing solid waste and ways of helping
municipalities uh handle it more
effectively so are there any questions
um if you like many of these committees
are interesting to me do you I'm
assuming you want an even number of
people on all the subcommittees yes can
I put down so you you put down your name
on anyone that you're interested in and
at least two
okay uh and then
um uh representative Aaron and I will
look through the list and try to create
balance committees that are balanced in
a partisan way and uh and try to make
try to make sure that the people who
have get their first inter first and
second interests okay thank thank you uh
the other thing about subcommittees is
that only a small fraction of bills go
to subcommittee uh so last term I don't
think we had
any uh Environmental Policy bills that
actually went to subcommittee we had
several Solid Waste bills that went to a
subcommittee one or two animal
protection bills that went to
um subcommittee
um
so it kind of depends on what the bills
are and uh whether they look complicated
and need to be amended or whether they
don't look complicated and don't need
Amendment so uh
so that that's so um
yeah that's pretty much uh the story
with the the subcommittees and
um we will uh representative air and I
will sort out the the lists and uh get
those out to you uh probably before at
thank you
and subcommittees
um they work pretty much the way the
regular larger committee works and so
far as they their meetings have to be
noticed to the public
um
there are minutes that have to be taken
they need to have a quorum
they also uh solicit information from
various agencies and
any anybody in the field who
can give them information to help them
work on the bill that they're working on
[Music]
um
they make eventually you know the
purpose is for them to get together and
make a recommendation to the larger
committee on you know what
what should be done if there's an
amendment that needs to be done to the
bill
they work on that
um
and the subcommittees will have chairs
and vice chairs just so it's just like
the larger committee
representative Bixby so one other note
is that uh if the subcommittee is
working on a bill you don't happen to be
on that subcommittee but that but you
are interested in it you are welcome and
encouraged to attend those subcommittee
sessions uh the only thing is that when
it gets to a voting for recommendation
you don't get to vote uh but you can
activate act you can
um work in a fairly uh active way with
the subcommittee even if you're not on
it
um and you just it's just that you
okay anybody have any questions oh
representative Creighton
yeah just for for those of you that have
not been on a subcommittee from my
perspective they're they're actually
pretty fun
because you really get into the details
of the state experts the
um different ngos the citizens that are
dealing with that bill and uh it's it's
where you can really get the meat of
compromise and figuring out second and
third order effects and um I just
encourage you to help out with the
subcommittees they're they're actually
thank you
yes
um Can the subcommittees also solicit
research from the research assistant and
then do they do that through their chair
or through you through me through you
hey anybody have any questions thus far
nope all right
okay
um
I'm sorry
oh the calendar okay
yeah okay so we have calendar notice um
the chair will provide as much notice as
possible for any activity done within
the committee however please check the
calendar for other important information
you know the house calendar comes out
once a week
and we have to get our meeting
information to them by Thursday
no by Wednesday
noon because the publication comes out
on Thursday
so
um
please make sure and check our the
calendar when it comes out so that you
can see what's going on with our
committee I'm going to pass this through
pass this down that way
and you will see you know when we have
subcommittee meetings and when we have
committee hearings and committee
meetings anything else
nope
um the other thing is is
um
Heather our assistant also will send us
emails as to when we have hearings
um and what bills what the calendar is
speaking of Heather
that's Heather goalie she is our house
committee assistant
and um
I'll talk we've already uh there she is
so I'm introducing uh
Heather goalie if you'd like to uh
introduce yourself tell us a little bit
about yourself and what you're going to
fishing games
labor legislative Administration
resources
yeah
thank you yeah okay wonderful
um
and can you explain your your uh Your
thank you madam chair Heather actually
make sure the train runs on time she
keeps us in line you are the gatekeeper
and uh she's been here since I can
remember
so
thank you and we love you
I have a little detail question do you
want
[Music]
just on the desk when we're done or do
community
this is
do we know when the name name plates are
committee and they they go on top of the
letter
every time you all meet
ings
I don't tend to set name things up for
some committees because it's a small
informal the name plates only go out
the name plates stay here they don't go
and if you are substituting in another
committee sometime if you're asked to
substitute in another exec session for
another committee
uh you will
because
okay
she really does make sure that the train
so I want to take this time to talk a
little bit more about our public
hearings
um
our public hearings really are the where
it all happens for us for in in our
committee in our committee work
because it is at that time where we can
truly hear from the public from agency
heads from lobbyists from all different
people
um
based on their expertise their feelings
their observations their knowledge
whatever about a particular
um
issue that we're having to deal with in
uh in a with a bill with a piece of
legislation
and you'd be surprised you know you you
think that um
something sounds pretty straightforward
but then somebody will come in and
throw a totally different
perspective on something and you just go
wow I never even thought of that
so uh the committee hearings to me have
always been very fascinating because
they just bring to light
although what ifs uh all the different
situations that can happen if this bill
ever gets put into law
and I think we end up being better
legislators by listening
so
um
it's a really great process and uh I'm
glad that we spend the time that we do
in the hearings uh listening to people
uh
tell us why a piece of legislation is
either good or bad
do you like to add anything to that
sure uh one of the things that's
important uh really important in public
hearings is uh is our decorum and the
way that we treat the people who are
testifying uh we all we must always be
respectful of the people who are
testifying and
um this is not an opportunity to grill
people it is a opportunity to elicit
information
uh so uh if you disagree with something
that a uh someone who's testifying is
saying you can ask for clarifying
information but you cannot say you're
wrong and you cannot ask a question that
boils down to saying you're wrong you
need to uh you can you know ask someone
who is testifying later on to you know
say so you say person a is testifying
and says one thing and you're not sure
that that's actually correct and and
testify testifier B seems to be saying
you know taking a somewhat different
angle you can ask for clarify testifier
B for for clarification on something
that testifier a might have said that
you're not sure about that that is fair
as long as you do it in a respectful way
to everyone
one of the things that is really
critical in this committee room and in
every every place that you meet the
public in the house and you meet your
fellow house members in the house is we
never impute motive we are looking for
facts we are looking for uh implications
of you know of policy we are not looking
we are not looking for motives if you
are saying if someone says that
um
person a is doing this because they have
this ulterior agenda that is right out
oh I will gavel them I will hit that
gavel
yes thank you so
um so the it is is critical that we
always keep in mind that we are
respectful of the Republic of the public
we are looking for as much information
as we can get out of them if it looks
like they're if something has been said
a number of different times you don't
need to ask a question to elicit that
same information again uh but if there
is an angle of it that doesn't doesn't
seem to have been covered then that is
appropriate so
we want to be as thorough as possible
without being particularly redundant
exactly
representative thank you madam chair and
when the public is testifying everything
that we do should be phrased in a form
of a question not a statement or an
opinion it should be an actual question
that we're asking them
and as a matter of formality that
question uh is channeled to the chair so
Madam chair
didn't mean to give you that unwanted
promotion I'm not I'm not ready for that
chair Madam chair
and and then
um the chair will recognize you and uh
then you ask the ask your present your
question to uh the person who's
testifying but essentially the chair is
always the person who is
um who is do basically modified and
doing the traffic management right and
so if you ask
you asked to be recognized by the chair
the chair will give you permission to
ask your question if you have a second
follow-up question you must ask also
it is also we have to take into account
people take a day off from work to come
and testify many times we must value
their time
we must respect that they're here and
make sure that they're heard and I want
to make sure
that everybody is heard in an equal way
um
that also in terms of advocacy
you know people in the who who are
coming to testify May wear buttons or
stickers to show that they are
supportive of uh or not supportive of
something but we should not
uh so we are here to listen and not to
be the ones
to show any kind of advocacy of any
particular Point representative Bixby
yeah
so just in terms of procedure uh for
members of the public who are here to
express an opinion on the bill there are
two ways they can do that actually three
ways they can do that uh at the front of
the um on the front desk there there
will be a blue sheet and there'll be
pink cards and the blue sheet is for
people who sign in who are not
interested in actually speaking uh the
pink cards are for people who would like
to uh
I would like to speak and those pink
cards are filled out and then brought up
to the chair and then the chair will
sort them roughly between people opposed
and people in favor of the bill people
who are so and uh the uh if and if other
reps are testifying or senators are
testifying they generally go to the
front of the queue so that they can get
back to their own committees
um
if Department chairs are testifying or
or or or people from uh the
administrative departments they often
are near the front of the queue as well
uh and then there's an effort to make
sure that everyone else is uh sorted uh
in a in a fair manner uh there's a third
way that
um since the since 2020 there's a third
way to make a comment which is that
there's a sign in that is available
online uh where you can sign in in favor
or against a bill and uh which is
similar to the blue sheet except that
it's um it's online and at the end of
each hearing we say how many people
signed in in favor how many people
signed in against both from a blue sheet
anybody have any questions
representative Dotsy
thank you madam chair uh is there going
to be any attempt during our session to
encourage people to keep to a time limit
and to
um you know if you have multiple people
from One organization to encourage them
to have a spokesperson rather than each
thank you in a short short uh answer
um
in terms of time limit I would have to
gauge that by how many people are in
attendance if we have a whole room full
of people I would make it so that
everybody's equally heard but that you
know we don't have somebody speaking for
five minutes another speaking for 10
minutes and so I uh I'm gonna gauge that
on um you know attendance basically
but um
I will likely if there is something
where there is a a whole lot of people
I don't want to hear the same thing over
and over and over again
and I would also encourage them to have
a spokesperson to say
you know what it is they support or not
any other comments
oh
representative Creighton has that been
the
where you've done it in your past
committee
yeah that that tracks
um
the big thing is to go through the chair
and
um
the one thing that that I've seen that
sort of drives me nuts um
is questions that go off track
in other words if if they're talking
about horses don't ask questions about
cows
um I I've seen that go awry and you know
that's the only thing I'd say okay thank
you
I also want to talk about
um if there's a Committee Member on our
committee here who is also a sponsor or
co-sponsor of the bill which we have a
and that bill comes before the committee
of course the sponsor introduces the
bill
um
but they can return to their seat after
testifying but if it now that's not
introducing a bill that's if they're
testifying on a bill okay so uh the uh
what we voted on last week yes was that
uh
you uh if you you can either uh testify
or you can uh participate in questioning
but you cannot do both right and I
believe that that is for co-sponsors I
believe if it if you're the sponsor then
you basically you you can't ask you
don't have the option of asking
questions because you introduced the
bill and you're speaking right on behalf
of the bill right right okay but if you
are a co-sponsor and you are not
speaking on the bill at all you uh then
have the opportunity to ask questions of
anybody else who's testifying on that
legislation
right okay everybody get that
okay
that's how it's always been done pretty
so anybody have any questions about Bill
hearings
yeah I just have one um
I was testifying it um for the last two
years a lot so there were some committee
chairs or that would run meetings and
give special
um
time for certain people and I just
wanted to see if that is going to happen
in this committee
well for historically what we've done is
because we know people like Senators
have to run between
uh hearings and uh and their work
we would give them the
opportunity to speak first that's fine
yeah uh and obviously the uh the person
who's introducing the bill they would
get first you know to speak
I don't know that I would give you know
any kind of uh
uh you know special treatment to anybody
often Department chairs Department
chairs departments who know the subject
matter in detail are given a little bit
the only other the other thing is that
uh typically the the speakers will
alternate between pro and con so you
don't have
all the pros go once and then all the
cons go it's it's back and forth so you
get sort of a balanced view so normally
you know senators or agency heads that
have time commitments
you know we want to hear from them first
and also the agency heads that may have
a little bit more experience and
but for the most part I mean we're going
to try and be as Fair as possible in
terms of alternating pros and cons pink
cards and make sure people every
everybody gets the equal treatment
mm-hmm
yes
representative thank you madam chair
um just for everyone that's new to this
committee historically in this committee
we have been fair with everybody
um and no one gets preferential
treatment that I have seen uh since I've
so that's about our hearings
executive sessions so the executive
session is a time in which we gather
together as a committee
and we vote
on what we want to do with any
particular piece of legislation
and we and render our committee
recommendation which will then obviously
go to the rest of the house
for them to decide whether we they agree
so the executive executive sessions are
scheduled just like the rest of any of
the other
committee meetings
they
would list specific bills and but an
executive session can be held the same
day as the hearing on the bill
I guess that that's a decision that we
would come together to make right so uh
the uh there would only be an executive
session that uh if uh the chair and I uh
agree on uh that that that that should
happen and it is not something that we
would typically do unless I I think
unless there's a real deadline or unless
there is a a really obvious reason to do
it I if it's if it's a bill where the
sponsor comes up afterwards and says
oops I shouldn't have submitted this
please IPL it then we might do it that
at that point we actually had one of
those last term right but
um but we don't we don't want any
surprises right but one of the things
about executive sessions is that part of
uh part of what an exact an executive
session is something where stakeholders
will show up if they're interested in
and uh they may and we want to make sure
that stakeholders have the opportunity
to see that executive session noticed
and know that it's coming up so we'll
generally so we it we will we want to
avoid doing exacting bills the same day
unless there's a particularly good
reason to do it
exactly
any questions
no
okay um so the proceedings and motions
in an executive session
um the way the way that that works is
the chair opens the executive sessions
and makes sure that everybody knows that
it's an executive session
we uh the chair will recognize committee
members for motions and a lot of times
those motions will be worked out ahead
of time so that you will know whether or
not you will be
um making a motion to on a pass or itl
something or do whatever else to it
um
and I
then we after the motion has been made
we will have a discussion about
uh
representative Kong
thank you madam chair is it still going
to be the practice that whoever makes
the motion writes the blurb I'm going to
call it or committee report yes that
would be that is true that if you're
going to make a motion to Auto pass a
particular bill you are going to be the
one writing the committee report uh
so yes representative Creighton yeah so
the the committee report for those of
you that are are new
um basically that's a short description
of the discussion
of why we voted a certain way
if it's a split decision then the
majority it goes first and then the
dissenting view goes second
typically that's put into the house
calendar
and so before you go to vote on it at in
the house
that's a clear understanding of what the
vote was in committee and the key
Salient points for why that vote was
taken and and
I've seen committee reports that go up
to two pages
um but most of them are probably about
four or five lines
okay I'm going to add something very
important about these committee reports
they are used in a court of law to
record intent of what the legislation
uh you know was
how the committee came to its
recommendation and
that it it reflects the intent of the
committee and so that's a very important
point to remember when you're writing a
committee report
and these committee reports are intended
to be clear and concise
um and and convey the reason why the
committee made or came to its
recommendation
um
representative Bixby another thing about
the committee report is that the
committee report gets
um
gets submitted to chair Aaron and she
will review the committee report to make
sure that everything is in order and uh
if it doesn't look like it's in order
then she will contact you and uh work
out whatever needs to be Rewritten
that's right
and I will expect the committee reports
to be done before you leave the day of
the hearing of the executive session
because
um all too often people say they're
going to write something and it ends up
being forgotten
um and and I I don't want
um
people in other departments like Paul
Smith yelling at me
so we're going to make sure that we get
our committee reports done when they
uh
let's see
when we um
we will be voting for The Motions our
clerk will be the one to be in charge of
that so would you like to go through
that whole
protocol
thank you madam chair so when the
question is put a motion is made by a
member of this committee uh and whatever
that motion is
um it'll be recorded I will then call
the roll
um and everyone will say yes or no there
is no abstention
um you must vote yet yay or nay
um once that's done I will record the
vote tally and let you know if the
motion passed or failed
um
and that's about it and it's
can go pretty quickly so but the role
will be called in the same order every
single time so you'll get used to when
your name is going to be called
um
um so one thing that uh if you haven't
been in a similar situation before uh
when you are voting you are voting on
the motion not on whether you like the
bill or not so uh if the motion for the
bill is itl or in expedient to legislate
then you are Mo your yes vote says that
bill should not go forward
uh and whereas if it's an ought to pass
then your yes vote means that bill
I also I want to uh can you explain a
little bit too to everyone about
amendments and the order in which we do
that
representative oh Peter representative
Bixby go ahead okay so
um when there's an amendment to the bill
uh the first thing we do is we move we
move the bill itself and then uh the
chair will ask if there are any um if
there's any discussion and we'll also
say if is there any uh are there any
amendments and at that point an
amendment would be moved and then the
amendment gets voted on
and if the amendment passes then the
next vote uh would be an ought to pass
with Amendment and uh if the amendment
doesn't pass the next vote would be an
ought to pass uh and if that's uh and
depending on what happens with that then
you know there are that could be further
complications uh we tend not to get into
a lot of further complications in
committee you'll see that happening a
lot on the floor
normally we only would have one
Amendment on any particular Bill
sometimes very rarely too
but we again we like to keep it very
simple
so um
that's how that's how that works for
voting
and the consent calendar
well upon completing our votes for a
particular bill
um I will ask the committee if there's
any objection to placing a bill on the
consent calendar if we have a unanimous
decision or I think uh it's it's either
that or one dissension
any bill with more than two navotes will
and go ahead representative Murray sorry
I saw her first
thank you madam chair and the one
exception is that if it's over ten
thousand dollars then it automatically
has to go is that correct yes that is
true
representative uh thank you madam chair
um there is an exception if there is one
nav out and they choose they say they
don't want it on consent calendar it
cannot go on consent correct
representative knob
um I just thought a question about the
changing the vote what's the process of
that like
so when the names have been called and
you voted
at what point would you if you wanted to
change your vote
it says you can change your vote before
the final vote is announced
uh ice I had uh heard that from our
committee researcher
but again no bills with any fiscal
impact or an appropriation above the
threshold of ten thousand dollars can be
a motion for reconsideration
um
would you explain that as well
sure
sometimes uh there is a a vote is taken
on a bill and uh then more information
comes forward Before the bill goes to
the house the Full House and if the bill
is still in the possession of the
committee the committee has the ability
to vote to reconsider the bill
and uh and
the first vote on that would be simply a
vote for reconsideration so uh and if
the vote for reconsideration fails then
it just goes to the house floor the way
that we voted it first if the
reconsideration passes then it is open
to further discussion and further
motions uh and uh and then there'd be a
new vote in terms on the ought to pass
or the Ito
um and uh then that subsequent vote is
what would be sent to the house floor uh
there cannot be more than one
reconsideration vote uh unlike in
uh on the house floor reconsideration is
not used as a way of sealing a vote so
it doesn't get changed right uh the in
in within committee it is it is really a
tool for if you get new information that
says you need to fix the bill then
um
it's a chance to do that
thank you representative Bixby I don't
believe I've ever seen that happen very
often anyway I think I've seen it like
maybe twice in six terms yeah
representative Murray
and just a point of clarification the
only way you can move reconsideration is
if you voted on the prevailing or
Winning Side is that correct it's not in
committee yeah okay it says so here
oh it does not I'm sorry thank you
but on the floor that's the case yeah
any questions
okay
moving along pretty good here
um
so
I will so we're pretty much done with um
with our executive session talking about
um meetings scheduling voting committee
reports
so we'll talk a little bit about field
trips
every so often uh yeah well again I know
you've been working on one I think uh
representative Bixby
all right sure well every so often we
will
to have a field trip we go we go out and
we look at something that UNH extension
and wants to show us or we go out to
um a dairy farm or an apple orchard or
you know some place where we are going
to be educated about a particular topic
and they they we typically organize
farms uh and other related tours we will
give you notice and and hope that you
can join in
um
this committee these field trips are
designed to to help us get educated on
any particular issues
uh some of them may be organized by
groups like Farm Bureau
um some of them may be organized by our
agency heads
um depends
right now we're working on putting
together something so represent Bixby
why don't you talk about that so um one
thing that uh I've we tried to do last
year and it just didn't come together so
we're going to make it work this year is
on doing a tour at UNH uh that includes
looking at Co-op extension looking at
the uh the animal Diagnostic lab and
looking at and getting information from
people in colsa the College of
Agriculture and Life Sciences uh and so
I'm going to be working with Folks at
UNH to get that scheduled I think we're
looking probably at late April or early
May
uh another uh thing that uh comes up
most years is uh the
um uh the Farm Bureau has a uh
has a legislative breakfast which is
usually coordinated with their new
farmer program and often will happen at
the
um the farm of their new farmer award
recipient and uh so we will have a
hosted breakfast and then get a chance
to tour the farm so that's something
that
um typically I believe happens at some
point in April when it's a little bit
easier to trudge around the farm
so those are a couple of things to look
forward to and another
um
thing that sometimes comes up is if if
we're working on a particular Bill and
doing a field trip will uh be will give
us material knowledge in terms of uh how
that you know how we should proceed
that's another possibility so uh or and
another thing is there are sometimes
sort of stakeholders who are typically
uh have bills that might come before
this committee so a few years back we
did a tour of the turnkey landfill in
Rochester and got to see their biogas
recapture program and um
uh so uh and there was an a number of
years back there was a
um
tour to the North country where we got
to see a farm stand that was uh looking
to have there was a bill that had to do
with some of the retail elements and uh
of how Farm stands work and we uh went
up to uh tour that farm and also toured
some other
um interesting uh establishments uh in
the same on the same trip because you
know we were up there anyway so we would
had a chance to see a number of
different things so those are all
um potential things for for field trips
and uh
if if it looks like a field trip would
be useful for any of the bills that
we're looking at this term then we may
in fact try to schedule that too
thank you and also you get mileage for
those field trips yep
I know that one of the fun part was last
year when we had the raw milk
Bill Froze that was for frozen raw milk
and uh and I got a chance to go to The
Little Red Hen and Sample the raw milk
um
so other than field trips uh sometimes
we will have a special presentations by
uh different
organizations
so those would be
um so when maybe we're through with the
bulk of our bills
we'll have an opportunity to learn more
about any specific
um
agency function I know we had a
presentation last year on invasive
aquatic species and it was very
fascinating
and they were very uh they were very
helpful and very thorough in their
presentation
so
anybody else have any questions about
we all ready to tackle these uh
16 bills that we have is six I think
and they look pretty reasonable I don't
see anything really out of uh out of the
ordinary here
so um I am going to try and sit down and
we'll figure out a schedule for when the
hearings for these will be we will try
and group them as to like
kinds of bills like we have a couple
having to do with uh Homestead food
operations
and then others that have to do with um
landfill stuff and
so I think we'll we'll have to sit down
and figure out how to put this together
so that it makes sense and that we don't
have
uh you know Miss Moss of things to deal
questions comments
and uh so we will be
um
we will be taking some time for lunch
I had originally scheduled uh our our
morning session to go to noon it looks
like we've we've flashed through
everything
so that we have an extra half hour
but at one o'clock I want you to come
back because we will have presentations
from our agency heads to begin then
from one o'clock
to 2 30 we'll have Department of
Agriculture and commissioner Jasper come
with his crew of folks to talk about his
agency and what they do and give us give
us some insight of
who's who
and then from 2 30 to 3 30 we'll be
talking with folks from the Department
of Environmental Services
and then from 2 30 to from yeah
2 30 to 3 30.
I'm sorry 3 30 to 4 o'clock we'll have
um Colleen Smith from Department of
Health and Human Services the Food
Safety Division
come in speak to us as well so it should
be a very interesting and informative
afternoon and I hope that you will be
back to hear it
representative kantois thank you madam
chair and the importance of hearing from
all of these committees is that all the
bills that we will be hearing are
directly related to these particular
groups so it's important to hear what
all right with that I will convene uh
this morning's session and I I I'm sorry
adjourn this morning session and I hope
to see you back at one o'clock
thank you for your attention and your
time and I appreciate it and I look
forward to working with all of you this
yes I feel comfortable with that yes
okay
oops
good afternoon everybody welcome back to
environment agriculture committee I hope
you had a pleasant lunch
a quick lunch Pleasant lunch however I
hope you filled your belly
I would like to take this opportunity to
welcome members of the Department of
Agriculture farms and markets and I will
turn this over to our esteemed
commissioner
my pleasure to be here
um certainly see a lot of new faces and
so we're going to give you a
presentation that really delves into
what we do in terms probably more
numbers so you get the scale of what the
department does
for those of you who are uh freshman
members of the House
I hope this was one of your top three
committees because I have to tell you
that when I was elected to the house in
environment AG was my first choice
Municipal encounty was my second I don't
recall my third and I ended up on
judiciary
which turned out to be very well uh a
good thing but I never did end up on
environment and agriculture so a little
special for me to now be the
commissioner
so
um
largely the Department of Agriculture is
about consumer protection
most everything that we try to do is to
protect the people of the State of New
Hampshire in one way or another I won't
delve into that the folks behind me Will
and rather that's being you know
protected from disease or invasive
species or people who would try to uh
under deliver the product they're
selling you whether that's uh meat by
weight or cord wood or any of those
things we do that a lot of people get
confused and think that that we do the
education
we don't that's Cooperative Extension
UNH I really do consider them to be our
sister organization we partner with them
constantly and they do a great job of
educating and they make life a lot
easier for all of us so I'm just going
to get into a little bit of the overview
in terms of
our budget
um
and things of that nature so
this year
the Department's budget
um
is about 7.6 million dollars
and our request moving forward uh
depending on whether you're looking at
the efficiency budget or our total
request
um
can range up as high as 8.8
the good thing about what we do is
taking away the things that are sort of
uh you know funding land preservation
funding the fares if you look at our
operations our people in our direct
expenditures
we are actually a revenue positive
agency
we bring in somewhere between two two
hundred thousand dollars to a million
more than than we expect I'm very proud
of that and I want to make sure we stay
that way I'm a fiscal conservative and I
I like to see that fact that we are
actually not a drain on the general fund
so money goes back and forth we keep
some in some funds some go back into the
general fund then we get general fund
but when you balance it all out we
maintain every year uh being Revenue
positive
and I don't think there's too many
agencies that that can say that out
there besides liquor probably but
um
that's a whole nother
we have
um 42 full-time
um excuse yeah we have 42 full-time
employees right now
um it's up from 36 when I became
commissioner
39 maybe I guess we had a number of
vacancies the years are going by it's
getting harder to remember what those
numbers were we have a request uh for
really converting one part-time person
to full-time it's not actually within
the department that's administratively
attached that is the state Conservation
Commission
um the last budget we were able to
finally get a part-time executive
director in there it's made the world of
difference in the world of State
conservation and um moving that person
to a full-time Position will also make a
huge difference so far the government
Governor has been supportive of that the
other priority that I have has been the
priority I really had since
um I became Commissioners understanding
the department that large
there's there's me now Dr Crawford is my
Deputy but he's busier than I am so it's
not like he he's just there if I'm away
on vacation he's the authority he's not
you know sharing in that workload
because his workload and his division is
now even higher than than mine quite
frankly but he does have it assistant uh
State veterinarian now
um so I am looking for an assistant
commissioner
um you know I rarely leave the office
for more than a couple of days at a time
because the paperwork piles up and
there's nobody there to do that and we I
don't have the opportunity to do the
strategic planning that I really ought
to
um when I became commissioner we did
take on fisma which is the food safety
modernization act from Health and Human
Services that has proven to be very
successful that's a totally federally
funded program and we have just got when
we took it over there was a full-time
position there I couldn't figure out
what a full-time person would be doing
at that stage so we went with part-time
people now it is time to move back to
having a full-time person there because
the program is growing it's it's one of
these that is staged based on the sales
of a farm and it keeps well going at a
very low level to a higher level and
we're moving up along that that chain
um so I'm very proud of the work that we
do in the Department of Agriculture and
I think we are a very efficient
organization you'll hear about what we
do when we do you know an awful lot of
work with very few people but I could
not even begin to do it without the
fantastic team that I have here
behind me some of them have been with
the department for many many years and
uh three are relatively new directors
one having already been with the
department for a while and others coming
on and they are all just doing a
fantastic job for the State of New
Hampshire I couldn't be prouder of the
people who serve as the directors of the
department and the staff who serves in
each of their divisions
what we hope to do here is give you that
overview I'd like to put questions any
questions off to the end we'll all
remain to be able to answer them but I
don't want to take away from any of
their their time
and so I'll be here for for questions as
well
um and so thank you very much and Dr
Crawford oh are you going to lead off
Jesus all right I don't want to break
our computer all right
good afternoon good to see some familiar
faces excuse me one moment absolutely
I just wanted to make sure everybody can
see the screens
yes okay
you got a question no okay thank you go
ahead what's that Madam chair thank you
good afternoon good afternoon
uh Steve Crawford I'm the state
veterinarian
the director of the division of animal
industry and as you heard from the
commissioner the Deputy Commissioner in
his absence
um
I've been trying for 17 and a half years
how to distill
what the what the division does into an
elevator speech and I have not figured
that out yet
uh so I'm going to take a little
different tact today for the intro
meeting and maybe focus on some of the
numbers it'll it'll sort of address what
we do but it'll give you numbers
attached to them just sort of a instead
of a concept or a theory
PIRA should I be using this for the
computer
okay
oh look at that all right
uh Department Mission here just because
I think it's useful to sort of frame
everything
General functions of the department
promoting and regulating Agriculture and
pay close attention to that sixth one
other duties as assigned
animal industry seems to have a lot of
those and I'm guessing other divisions
do as well
the definition of agriculture oh you're
our division Mission so this why the
division of animal industry exists
controlling contagious and infectious
diseases
in particular those ones that can affect
humans and I apologize I'm trying to
make eye contact but missing somebody
around the the implements here
protecting public health and the economy
and the environment frankly now and as
we look forward at one Health and more
modern approach and then our animal
population control program that we'll
I didn't realize this was animated I'm
sorry
a little slower than I thought so
estimates of the numbers of animals in
the state
avma demographics some USDA censuses and
some other places where we've pulled
these together from
that one in the top right because of the
ongoing High path Haven influenza
outbreak I thought was useful to
highlight
that one is based on a 2004 USDA census
a backyard vlogs
dated data but I would challenge anybody
here to drive down two or three dirt
roads in the state and not see a cooler
or a sign for eggs somewhere
my guess is those numbers have gone up
since 2004. but 34 000 backyard flocks
in New Hampshire
tuberculosis testing
so we need to statistically to get 4 900
some animals tested cattle tested each
year to maintain our free status that
gives our producers lots of latitude to
move animals back and forth across state
lines to slaughter without extra
regulatory burden
2021 the last complete year
2260 of those through Slaughter
we tested ourselves 1639 so we're still
there's a new england-wide mou or memo
that USDA acknowledges that lets us use
other states data to maintain our status
they put up a rhetorical question for
you there do you find are you do you
find comfort in that using other states
data to maintain our status
I'm not sure how we would get the other
thousand we just don't have the time or
the bodies but it some of the things
that we deal with Interstate movement
documents thousands of those that we've
verify review each year
little rabies is largely a local
responsibility but we deal with over 300
calls a year questions from local
authorities who don't know the details
questions from veterinarians questions
from people who are bitten by dogs or
cats and want to know the details of
what to do
many dozens of quarantines poultry
places other livestock each year that we
try and manage
in a fairly new thing that is necessary
but becomes sort of a challenge
lots of small poultry flags that end up
with disease don't want those birds
anymore
we are now a euthanasia surface for a
lot of those small flock owners because
they have no other option
and so we work with our wildlife
services folks we have a trailer that we
use with carbon dioxide to euthanize
birth we do a fair amount of that never
something I even envisioned as part of
the Department's job but there's nowhere
else to get that done and I think it's
an important thing for Disease Control
and Animal Welfare to figure out how to
do it if we don't do it
uh I am the the state's lead for
emergency support Function 11 to the
state Emergency Operations plan that is
agriculture cultural and natural
resources it's not just agriculture so
I'm responsible for helping dncr Des
fish and game and others sort of
mitigate plan for the disasters that
might affect them as well
monthly meetings lots of planning stuff
goes into that
uh I hold
Devin by my account up there DEA
registrations
I hold one for my office we don't have
any drugs there
we need to keep that though in case we
needed them for an emergency I hold five
for state fish and game because you have
to be a veterinarian or an MD to hold
the DEA registration and fishing game
doesn't have a veterinarian on staff
I hold one for each of their field sites
and one for their headquarters and I
also hold one for USDA wildlife services
so I'm responsible for the risks that go
along with that and annual Audits and
some other stuff Pharmacy boards
actually coming to my office tomorrow
tomorrow to destroy all the stuff that
I've collected from them in the last
year that's outdated from the last
thought so it's something that we do for
them on a regular basis
working off a lot with HHS Fish and Game
Homeland Security who has been fantastic
to us frankly during the uh
High path AI outbreak they have built an
online mapping tool that we can use when
we plot a location of a farm that might
be infected it will automatically show
us the 10 kilometer 20 kilometer circles
and the places that we need to contact
so they've been wonderful to help us
with that it's not I.T capacity that we
have ourselves and going through
spreadsheets is not the way to do that
anymore either
uh
deal with several cases per month with
law enforcement Animal Welfare stuff
we're working up one now with the town
uh calls weekly but actively on farms
with police at least a couple times a
month to deal with Animal Welfare cases
the poultry numbers I thought were
interesting fairly consistent uh Little
Drop in the first year of the pandemic
and a bump in the next couple of years
lots of people wanted Birds
the 9-3 those are the import documents
for poultry and I thought that was
useful
approaching 300 000 Birds imported
last year to individuals and feed stores
that's not our big poultry players
that's just the individual folks and
that's for who we have records I would
bet you there are plenty that we don't
3 200 New Hampshire residents individual
New Hampshire residents that imported
Birds last year
and then our livestock dealers which is
largely our poultry stores are pardon me
our feed stores that sell poultry
imported about 80 000 Birds themselves
or 90 000 Birds pardon me uh
we have to have an initial State
response and containment plan in order
for any of our poultry producers that
are affected by hypothetic qualify for
Indemnity we submitted that a couple of
years ago to USD USDA for approval and
they haven't approved it yet they've
been busy with the high path AI stuff
and they've also paid our producers so
far so I think we're okay but getting
some of the planning stuff done like the
commissioner said finding time to do the
office work is a challenge
uh we do regular testing for four New
Hampshire poultry Farms that ship to
slaughter in New Jersey because they're
they required that testing
we don't have any veterinarians in New
Hampshire outside of our department that
are comfortable doing that testing so
somewhere around 15 on-site visits last
year to those Farms so they could send
anywhere from 500 to 1500 birds at a
time down for Slaughter
these are not poultry specific Farms but
these are all people who are farming for
a living no off farm jobs and they
together they employ 40-ish I think when
I did the numbers 40 people that these
four small farms are employing keeping
hundreds of Acres open if we don't
provide that service for them they don't
have the poultry piece of their business
uh other duties as assigned so the
biggest single consumer of our people
resources is regulating the pet trade
not agriculture but it's our single
biggest people consumer
a little over three fdes to deal with
that and just 150 license holders
it's an enormous task
it's a
it's a challenging group to deal with
um
it it is it is it's a challenging group
in terms of the revenue generation
Revenue neutral 200 license for the year
we license 150. so 30 000 ish dollars
you would generate
we spend three ftes worth of time and
salary on that plus fuel and other stuff
it's not a revenue neutral thing I don't
know how it would be uh and I'm not
suggesting that it should be necessarily
but that's that's one of those things
and I will likely be in front of you
more often for pet vending than for
anything else
and I work for the Department of
Agriculture
our spay and neuter plan our program
pardon me first in the country
established in 1994. about 5 000
applications a year from mean means
based residents of New Hampshire
I want their dogs or cats spayed or
neutered five thousand applications a
year
at just five minutes to review each of
those for content and accuracy that's
three months of Staff time just to
review the application not the processor
to do anything else
uh database RFP update I was actually
asked about it when I came in so last
year
we thanks to your assistance we got the
authority and funding to establish
an electronic database for records
management
we need to get into the 2000s
uh many months later the state is slow
I signed off on the final approval of
RFP yesterday and commissioner Goulet
signed off on it today so by the end of
the week our RFP will be posted it will
be open for 60 days I believe
uh at which point we will review all the
applications with a team from oit and
from our department and from the
Department of Justice
in my our timeline was by July 1st to
have someone chosen for a contract we're
about we wanted to have the RFP posted
December 31st so we're 10 days to two
weeks behind so still hoping for July
1st to get that contract signed it still
sort of stays in line with what the
statute established for us last year as
a timeline
uh High path Avon influenza outbreak
that you've heard about in the news
and I don't want to go over time I can
stop any let me see
it's probably time for me to wrap it up
so ongoing High path they have an
influenza outbreak we have had two
backyard flocks affected
that has had implications for all four
of those flocks I told you about that
shipped to New Jersey because we have to
change testing and movement status and
for some of our big poultry players
because this is no longer just about
disease it's about politics with other
countries and other states so
even though we've only had
folks that aren't part of the
traditional industry affected it has
affected more than a handful of other
farms in the state it's a real deal
issue
uh plenty more for there to there for
you to read I'll be here for questions
and you guys can all find me by phone or
email or walking across the street
thank you well do you want me to let you
good afternoon honorable members of the
environment and agriculture committee
I'm David Russo I'm the director of
division of pesticide control so thanks
for serving for the citizens of the
the images that um that we use to in
this presentation today shows some
important pieces to
pesticide concerns in regards to
protection of human health in the
environment and and this is actually
current images we're using with training
that we do the commissioner mentioned
the University of New Hampshire
Cooperative Extension we do partner with
them on training individuals that are
interested in getting a license and I'll
explain uh when you'd need a pesticide
license or individuals that already hold
a license that need to do continuing
education requirement commitments so we
have a strong focus on the importance of
that message protecting human health and
the environment in regards to pesticide
control
uh the statute does allow for pesticide
use as long as pesticides are used in a
proper and inappropriate manner so the
statute does allow for use in in the
division's mission is really to make
sure that that that's the way things are
actually going on in reality
um and the way we do that is this five
program areas we have licensing and that
that all has to do with exams and
we have an enforcement section within
the division and we do have inspectors
that go out make sure that folks that
hold licenses they're actually doing
things the way they're supposed to be
doing we also respond to complaints
there's a product registration piece the
statute requires that any product
pesticide product that sold and
distributed in the state of New
Hampshire is registered with the state
so we we're just register um pesticide
products
we do have an Environmental Protection
and an integrated Pest Management
program so those are the five major
areas so integrated Pest Management uh
for folks not familiar with it is a a
concept some folks will call it a
science or an art but it's really an
approach to a pest that doesn't just
identify pesticide as the as the reason
uh response so integrated Pest
Management is including other things
like mechanical control Behavior
cultural and and that sort of thing so
those are the five major areas within
the division of pesticide control as far
as numbers go is our deliberables
deliverables from um from 2022 last year
we issued 2 600 licenses so folks that
needed a pesticide license we had 2 600
of those the number of products
um inspections we did 600 inspections
and we issue a special premise a special
permit goes above and beyond holding a
license and these are usually required
in sensitive areas like nearby water
resources and the environmental section
within our division reviews those
requests for use of pesticides in those
sensitive areas so we did 360 of those
last year
um a point I wanted to make about
product registration the manufacturers
of products they have to register it
with the state and the the fee that they
pay goes to the integrated Pest
Management program and that supports
some of the division as well as grants
so the Staffing how we do this we have
uh one individual that's the
administrator that would be me the
director a certification coordinator
that's the person that makes sure that
people um are licensed properly that
they go through the examination process
that they renew their licenses on time
we have the Environmental Protection
Program manager
and one individual that reads views I
mentioned the 600 inspections that we do
this this position this enforcement
worker protection manager reviews each
one of those cases to determine the
proper enforcement action whether it's
just a field notice or it might be a
fine
and then we have two inspectors to cover
the whole state
the nice thing with the state of New
Hampshire inspect is they don't just
qualify for the state standard they also
hold Federal credentials for pesticide
inspections so they they hold a dual
and then we have an individual that
oversees those registration of the 13
000 pesticide products
and yesterday I had an interview for a
product assistant that's the only one
we're missing right now and hopefully
we'll have that that position filled and
that position rotates among the
different programs just as an assistant
sort of piece so that's the Staffing
piece we have eight individuals
for the five major programs I'm going to
mention some major topics one of them we
may see is a bill we've seen it as a
legislative service request and that's a
a ban on a certain class of rodenticides
um so so I guess you'll be hearing more
from me on that the division does not
support a ban there's a great concern
with with rodents particularly rats and
mice but we'll go into detail when we
when we cover the bill but that's one of
the major topics we're involved with
um training we do uh partner with a uni
particularly the University of New
Hampshire but actually any trade group
that comes to the division and requests
the speaker especially in regards to
what the regulations mean and and
offering assistance compliance
assistance we do we do uh Outreach and
training
um that's a major topic another major
topic is the abavaral disease in regard
to mosquitoes and some of the diseases
that they carry such as West Nile Virus
Eastern equine Encephalitis and we work
close with the division uh with the
Department of Public Health and Human
Services
and an integrated Pest Management we're
constantly trying to keep that in
people's minds that the response to a
pest doesn't always need to be a
chemical so that's a continuing major
project and the federal government has a
a piece regarded to agriculture it's
called worker protection and this is
pretty much Farms that use workers and
the worker protection standard is so
that the farmers the owners are reaching
out to make sure that those workers
understand
pesticides and precautions to take so
that that limit exposure so those are
our major some of our major topics we do
get involved with a lot of other topics
as well I wanted to mention some of our
government Partners again we work
closely with the University of New
Hampshire on training and research we
work closely with department
environmental services especially water
quality pieces Health and Human Services
I mentioned that with the mosquito we
also had a project for Health and Human
Services on ticks a couple years ago in
regards to Lyme disease we do we are
supported by some federal money through
the United States Environmental
Protection Agency so we work closely
with the with vpa
and Fish and Wildlife and right now the
most current fish and wildlife project
we're working on is the is the tracking
of animals that have been identified as
having residue from rodenticides so
that's a really important piece right
now
so those are some of our Partnerships
the last thing I want to leave the last
three slides and this is really digging
in the weeds but I always I always
wanted to do this because from where you
sit you may not know the standard that
someone would have to go through for a
license or a permit but there is an exam
requirement okay and it's a high
standard
um
and there's two types of pesticide
applicators one is commercial some that
might be someone that that we may hire
to come to the house to deal with
cockroaches or or the lawn and then
there's private which is more of the
agriculture based uh individual but the
exam is um it's written okay and it's
closed book
um for commercial pesticide license if
you go on someone else's property and
you use a pesticide you need a pesticide
license so
um that exam is three parts we have core
which is your basic pesticide
information on safety how to read a
label the category focuses is on on
focuses in on the site that you're
working at so we have 23 different types
of categories for example if you're
working just in lawns that would be the
turf category and we have a separate
category for for example structural
dealing with termites and that sort of
thing so you have the koi category and
then a regulations portion of the exam
now there's a advanced level required
for every company
and it's called the supervisory level
license and that's not just the written
exam but they come in for an oral exam
and they have to pass the written to
take the oral and the um oral exam is
like an interview and we asked that
individual questions we usually like to
have a a panel of three people one a
subject matter expert a regulation
expert and then a generalist so that's a
commercial license that's the exam
requirement and then the private which
is really the agricultural type permit
we refer to all them as licenses but
this is actually technically a permit
anyone using pesticides in the
production of a commodity for sale or
distribution has to have a a permit and
again it's three-part three-part exam I
wanted to leave you with that just so
when we do talk
um in regards to bills that you
understand the person that holds a
license that does it professionally
that's the um the standard they're held
to so that's all I have and thank you
appreciate it
good afternoon my name is Paris siegert
I'm the state entomologist and I'm the
director of the division of plant
industry
so I wanted to start with just a few
numbers here and so well first our
mission is to promote and protect plant
Health by curtailing the spread of
dangerous insects diseases and weeds
moved in Commerce
um
there can be sometimes I think a little
bit of unclarity uh between what we do
versus what division of force and lands
does versus what Cooperative Extension
does and we partner with all of those
organizations and I hope in my next
slide to kind of try to highlight a
little bit where what we do is distinct
from what they do we have four full-time
Personnel we have my position as a state
entomologist we have two entomologist
twos and one entomologist one and we
have one part-time apiary inspector
our funding from General funds is just
over four hundred thousand dollars we
get a little bit under two hundred
thousand dollars in federal grants and
that's going to vary from year to year
and then last year the Upland invasive
species remediation fund was created and
that's a cost share fund for treatment
using herbicides for invasive species
um so if you look at our website which I
have listed there and which is on the
handout that has gone out to you I
prepare a report every year on the
activities of the previous year the
report that's up there right now is
2021's report
um I'll start working on 2022's report
pretty soon and I think also handed out
to you or being handed out to you is
basically a front and back page summary
of that 28-page report
um so anytime you want to look and see
what we're doing it's there in a lot of
detail
so we can't do this job alone we have a
lot of Partners in terms of our plant
protection framework it goes from the
state level which was what we do here at
the New Hampshire Department of
Agriculture uh to the between state
level harmonizing regulations through
the national plant board uh the federal
level which is uh USDA animal plant
health inspection service plant
protection and quarantine afis PPQ the
Continental level which is the National
North American Plant Protection
Organization which is comprised of
Canada the United States and Mexico and
then the International Plant protection
convention which is 211 countries that
are trying to harmonize plant pest rules
in order to reduce the transfer of pass
across borders while still promoting
trade and plants and plant parts so we
have a network of folks that we're
trying to work with at every single
level to reduce the spread of pests and
then we have a lot of non-regulatory
Partners and Cooperators years only some
of whom I have listed here because I
knew I was going to run out of space on
this slide
if I look at plant protection activities
there's Continuum of activities with
invasion of plant pests so plant pests
can be insects it can be pathogens they
can be weeds etc etc first you have you
know pre-detection you have don't have
the plant pest in that area then you
move into the early detection phase
where something has been introduced but
it's not widespread yet and then you get
to the point where it's established a
lot of our activities actually are
happening in the before and early stage
we don't do management and that's where
you're going to get into like division
of force and lands may do more
management when you have an agricultural
pest on that is in somebody's field they
might look to Cooperative Extension to
give them some guidance we don't offer
that kind of guidance and so we have
different activities and tools that we
use depending on what stage of invasion
you are by a plant pest some of them we
do throughout we're going to license
plant dealers regardless of whether or
not they there are plant pests in the
area we're going to do inspections to
make sure that plants being offered for
sale are apparently free of plant pests
and we're going to do certification and
compliance activity so that if they want
to ship to another state even though we
have Japanese beetle in New Hampshire we
can certify and comply your plant
shipment so we can go to Oregon where
they don't want Japanese beetle so we do
that regardless of the stage of the
infestation then there are some
activities that we don't do once a pest
becomes established once a pest is
established my division does not survey
once a pest is established my division
really kind of backs off a lot on the
Outreach and education that we do that
gets taken over by other entities that's
going to be your extension your division
of forests and lands and then quarantine
is a tool in the toolbox that is used
sometimes exterior quarantines are those
that
work to reduce the likelihood of a pest
coming into the state so we're going to
use an exterior quarantine when there's
a pest nearby that we don't want an
interior quarantine is where you're
trying to either control the movement of
the pest within the state or if there is
a commercial and economic reason to
continue maintaining a quarantine in
order to ship to other places we'll use
an internal quarantine
so plant dealers this is I always
describe this as kind of our bread and
butter there's nothing like a live plant
for moving a live plant pest their food
source is moving with them so we do a
lot of regulations of of plant dealers
and so we work with the green industry
to facilitate trade and protect the
public through surveys and inspection
beekeeping we have a part-time apiary
inspector and we maintain an apiary and
provide assistance to New Hampshire's
beekeeping industry this is a very small
program
and then the wood products industry
since the 1970s there's been a big
increase in the number of introduced
pests into this country that have moved
in Wood Products
um and so depending on the past we will
work with the producers of firewood logs
Lumber chips
um all sorts of crazy things end up in
this wood products
um uh kind of commodity stream there
including like rabbit chew toys little
things in pet stores will end up
sometimes we have to deal with because
somebody's found a plant past in them
so some of these activities we have 917
licensed plant dealers in 2022 and 660
different entities have registered their
Apiaries at some point we do not have a
mechanism for removing Apiaries from
that list so this is up to date this is
how many have have asked to be
registered
um last year we did 580 Nursery
inspections we did 33 apiary inspector
consults where they call on the phone
and the apiary inspector can actually
resolve a lot of these through emails
photos phone calls eight of them
required him to go to the location to to
do a further inspection and the USDA
issues permits for various insects or
soils that come into the come into the
state and I have to approve those so we
did 142 of those
we issued 20 compliance agreements for
for producers to say that they meet
certain requirements to facilitate
shipping to other locations we issued
183 phytosanitary certificates to move
mostly plants to other states that have
a requirement for that level of
certification we issued 14 phytosanitary
certificates to ship plans to Belgium
Canada France Netherlands Poland and the
UK and all of that comes with a suite of
requirements that we have to review and
then specific activities that we have to
do to make sure that those plants are in
compliance with their import
requirements Diaz Cole Growers is the
only Greenhouse in the country that is
dually certified under the greenhouse
certification program which is a trade
agreement between Canada and the U.S as
well as the voluntary sank systems
approach to Nursery certification
program they've really led the way on
that I believe that we got DS coal
Growers finally certified under the gcp
at the start third of 2020 and since
that time they've had a 63 percent
increase in the number of shipments that
they've sent to Canada I don't want to
say that that's solely because of being
in the gcp there's probably a lot of
other factors also that have led to that
but it certainly has made it easier for
them to certify their own shipments to
Canada under that program we certify
firewood kelens seven of them in the
state that are shipping their firewood
to states with a regulatory strategy so
if the state says we need firewood
certified to this heat treatment level
to enter our state we have certified
those Kilns to do so this is our
actually our certification period for
firewood uh kiln's right now so we just
got our probes yesterday and are
starting to go around the state today to
to certify those Kilns which is an
annual activity we partner with Growers
for pest survey and Export certification
we reach a diverse audience via many
means and often partner with extension
on events the more eyes that are out
there looking for insects and other
plant pests the easier our jobs are so
we see this as a core function
our invasive species program so in
addition to our rules we provide
trainings and information on eradicating
invasive plants we cooperate on
management and demonstration projects
um so last year as I mentioned there was
the establishment of the Upland invasive
species remediation Fund in the creation
of the Upland invasive species
coordinator position those were
highlights to date with these
demonstration projects that we're
involved with we've treated 161 Acres of
Japanese knotweed and right-of-ways
26.5 Acres done with Woody foliar
treatments about 38 000 spot treatments
of Woody invasive plants and we've been
managed about just under 5 000 tree of
heaven so just a moment here to to point
out a couple of things that on our
website we have this New Hampshire guide
to Upland invasive species as well as
the manual preventing the spread of
Japanese knotweed these are both really
popular for people they like to they
like to look at these the Japanese
knotweed manual has been distributed to
all of the dot districts for use as well
as every municipality received one for
when they're doing land moving projects
the New Hampshire guide to Upland
invasive species gets distributed
everywhere people request it pretty
regularly tree of Heaven is a preferred
host for spotted lanternfly which is a
pest which is uh kills grapes and and is
likely to cause some regulatory concerns
if it becomes established in New
Hampshire it doesn't need tree of Heaven
to survive but it grows faster and
leaves more offspring if it can feed on
tree of heaven so reducing tree of
Heaven does reduce the likelihood of
establishment of spotted lanternfly
we surveyed for 26 different pests that
are considered of risk to New Hampshire
Agriculture and the environment which
are not established in the state last
year this year we're on task to survey
for 32. we did 31 tick identifications
where folks sent in ticks for us to ID
28 identifications of insects and
spiders and then we had two likely
delusional parasitosis
situations which I'm not going to go
into in too much detail but if you want
to talk to me about it at some point I'd
be more than happy to describe what that
is
so our challenge is always our budget
Personnel we do a lot for four people
online retailers is kind of the Wild
Wild West in terms of what's happening
in terms of people moving plants around
and whether people are in compliance or
not that's um true in every single state
and we're all struggling to understand
how to really fit them into the
framework and then anytime we have
impacts to our federal Partners that's a
line of protection that isn't there
anymore that we then kind of take up the
slack on and so so what's happening to
our federal Partners is important to us
we have a variety of different websites
our division website nhbugs which is a
multi-agency cooperation has a lot of
information primarily about Forest pests
there's an active Facebook page with
that and I think that's it happy to
thank you
hello everyone my name is Cheryl air I'm
the director of weights and measures
um I am one of the new ones that has not
presented to the committee thus far
I became the director in 2019 but I have
been with the division since 2006.
um the Division of Weights and measures
is a really really important division
that a lot of people don't even know
about John Quincy Adams said weights and
measures may be ranked among the
necessaries of life to every individual
of human society and I 100 percent
believe this statement weights and
measures
affects each one of you every single day
whether you're driving your car buying
fuel whether you're buying food whether
you're buying packages from the grocery
store for your dog food or buying your
pesticides all of those have a weight or
measure on them as a declaration of what
you are purchasing so we do
um
we do touch everybody's life every
single day
the Division of Weights and measures
mission statement
um is not necessarily just about
consumer protection it is about equity
in the marketplace because those
businesses where we are buying products
from those business owners are consumers
as well but they're also
um in direct competition to the other
businesses just like them and so as we
look at equity in the market we are
looking to make sure that we as
individuals are getting
fairly
fair
prices and product given to us but also
making sure that the businesses are are
successful because they are competing
with each other as well and so we want
to make sure that they are abiding by
the laws and regulations so that it is
in our um our staff we have seven
full-time staff members and we have one
part-time staff member
um I oversee the whole weights and
measures program a lot of it is
Administrative
um
communicating with different individuals
and businesses when violations are
um
are had we have a program specialist who
oversees all of our service technicians
and way Masters she's the one that
answers the general line and takes
consumer complaints which we get a fair
amount of we have a program assistant
who oversees all the businesses that are
licensed and those businesses are ones
that have weighing and measuring devices
that they use commercially we have a
metrologist now
um our Metrology lab houses all of our
I'll show another slide about the
Metrology lab in a little bit but
um he's been with us since the beginning
of 2020
um our he has been studying and getting
the lab in a position where we can
actually open it up for use which is a
great accomplishment because it takes a
lot of
um Manpower and know-how to get that up
and running our lab went down in 2015
because the pers the person that was in
that position was actually
um
asked to come work for the National
Institute of Standards and technology
and he took that position
which left us without a metrologist and
we did look for quite some time for
someone to fill in that position but it
is a very very difficult position to
fill and it takes a unique type of
person to fill that and so it's been a
struggle but we finally got one in 2020
he's been working very hard to get our
our lab up and running and
um the good news is is that it's going
to happen very soon so we're happy about
that in 2020 our our office
um
oh let me finish going through these we
have one part-time metrologist who
actually was the director of weights and
measures when I came on board in 2006.
he has come back to help us get our lab
up and running and then we have Three
Investigators our state is
um
divided up into six different areas and
each of our investigators has two of
those areas
with that
um
a big part of our role and
responsibility is to make sure that we
know where those devices are that are
being used commercially
the state also has allowed service
companies to have licensed service
technicians who are generally the ones
who are going out and state certifying
so we don't we do some in-house
certifying but the majority of all the
certification that is done
um by these licensed service technicians
um
it comes with its challenges because we
don't have Hands-On for all of those
devices ourselves to make sure that
they're doing the proper examination
procedures on those devices every year
because they need to be certified every
year and so
um we have two thousand I mean 210
service technicians we have a thousand
twenty five way Masters that are
licensed with us and those are the
individuals who are given the authority
to produce weight tickets when a vehicle
scale is being used so we're it's when
they're moving large commodities
um we also licensed 20 000 commercial
weighing and measuring devices that are
so we also have an enforcement piece and
this is a huge piece because of all
those 20 000 plus the people that we
license so the weighing devices as you
may well guess you know it's anywhere
from jewelry scales Deli scales all the
way up to Big vehicle scales we have
measuring devices you know your gas
pumps
um oil and propane delivery meters that
furnish us with home heating fuel
we have
checking the net content and volume
of packages
we have price verification making sure
that the price on the Shelf is what
you're getting at the register we have
unit price verification which
um a lot of people don't
May pay attention to but it's used in
order to do value comparison between one
product and another that are of similar
type
we have packaging labeling compliance
this is where
um you know different agencies
throughout the state have packaging and
labeling requirements but we also do too
and so some of the challenges that we
Face are making sure that people
understand that they don't just have to
meet the requirements of one agency but
there are several agencies that may be
involved in packaging and labeling
requirements we also get a lot of
complaints regarding the sale of
firewood so we we partner with plant
industry with forestry we've done
presentations to help people understand
how to actually measure the amount of
firewood that they are getting and how
to determine if they were fairly dealt
with
we also do audits of businesses those
service technicians because they're the
ones out there doing the state
certifying and I want them to be doing
it the correct way
and also way Masters
this is just one of our investigators
that was out using some of our equipment
to test the measure of fuel at a
we also do educational Outreach
um to the regulated Community because we
think the most one of the most important
things is to educate people if people
don't know how to
um abide by the regulations then it's
not going to do any good for us to
expect it of them if they don't know
about it so we do a lot of of Outreach
just one small example is the New
Hampshire Farm forest and garden expo we
do scale clinics for New Hampshire
agricultural businesses which has been
very successful we used to have people
going out to the individual Farms to do
all the farm scales but we found that it
was not a very good use of our time so
we have devised a way to have 11 or 12
scale clinics throughout the year so
that farmers and those who are in the
agriculture Community can come to us and
we will certify their scales for free so
that is a great benefit to our
agricultural Community we also partner
in some things with the New Hampshire
grows Grocers Association so that they
have information on how how best
practices are when selling commodities
and then science technology engineering
and math is really important it's one of
the stem programs and weights and
measures Falls right in line with that
especially with our Metrology lab just
recently we went to the Nashua School of
Science and design and taught six
classes to 12 and 13 year olds so that
they could understand what weights and
measures was all about because I would
dare say that um there's a a lot of
individuals adults out there that have
no idea what weights and measures is and
the Metrology lab we do maintain the
state's
um standards these standards are used
when they are doing calibration work in
the lab
every state was provided by the federal
government a set of standards and so we
we highly prize these we have
thousands hundreds of thousands of
dollars of equipment in our Metrology
lab so it's really important for us to
make sure that this is a successful
Endeavor there aren't very many Labs
throughout the country and when our lab
went down it was a huge
um
it like it hurt
um not only just our state but other
states because sometimes other states
send their equipment to us for
calibration and so it's really important
for us to get that up and running as
soon as we possibly can because
um not only are they certifying the
equipment that we use out for our field
standards but it's also the the field
standards that our service technicians
are using to test the equipment that's
um we also in partnership with a
different few different organizations
this is not an exhaustive list but we
work a hundred percent in conjunction
with the National Conference on weights
and measures
um this is a professional non-for-profit
Association of state and local weights
and measures officials federal agencies
manufacturers retailers and consumers so
you as an individual could be a member
of that conference as well they what we
do is we work to develop national
weights and measure standards and that
has been happening since 1905. the
organization brings the right interests
together to keep Pace with Innovative
advancements in the marketplace and
right now we are really focusing on
electric vehicle charging stations
because they're just becoming so more
prevalent currently we are we have no
equipment to test those devices there is
some test equipment that has come about
that we are are very interested in
utilizing but we one do not have the
funding for it and we don't have the the
manpower to do that so somehow we're
going to have to come up with a means of
keeping up with technology and the
advancements in the market
we also partner with the National
Institute of Standards and Technology
their office promotes uniformity equity
and sius and traceability in weights and
measures by advancing National and
international legal Metrology standards
test procedures capabilities and
training the individuals with nist they
are our subject matter experts because
there are so many devices in the market
right now we can't possibly know
everything about every single individual
device and so
we have them as our resource and we
utilize them they probably hear from us
more often than they would like but they
are also always so
um gracious in answering our questions
and helping us to figure out the right
way to do something
we also work with local law enforcement
when when it's necessary we work with
UNH Cooperative Extension Office they
are a great race resource for
information and they are the ones that
help us to have helped us in the past to
get places that we can hold our scale
clinics des and Dot have also
collaborated with us on a few important
topics such as refueling issues and
some of the challenges that we have
um
paying employees a competitive salary
resources to purchase needed equipment
software programs that are up to date we
have had a software program that has not
been supported since 2007 it was
actually initially started in the the
program itself was developed in the 80s
the early 80s and we have been working
on another
venture since 2 May of 2016 when a
contract was signed we still do not have
a product so may have this year we still
do not have a usable product
to replace what we currently have and so
um
I know that the commissioner is very
supportive of us getting the needed help
but it's it's things such as technology
and keeping up with the times we still
can't take credit cards and so there are
things that we are lacking that would
help us to advance so much more if we
had
um the support of proper software and
such
um
we have a declining service technician
pool you saw that we have 210 service
technicians back in 2017 when the last
person gave this presentation we had
280.
um and we have we have inquired about
that it's a declining it's an aging
um
service technician pool
it's harder to get young people to want
to go into the trade
and with that some of that will end up
relying on us and our investigators in
order to do some of that work but it is
very difficult to
um our laws and rules are very old
um it's some of the challenges that we
have is that it's a slow process and
I personally would actually love to have
some guidance and in cleaning them up
both the laws and roles because some of
them are no longer applicable some of
them need to be updated so that it
includes some of these newer
Technologies and such
that is all I have so I look forward to
thank you for such an interesting
presentation on such a weighty prod
issue
thank you
great
what's being passed out now is
approximately uh is is a copy of
approximately 30 slides I do not intend
to go through all 30 slides but what you
have there is information necessary to
get into the depths of some of the
programs that I or we offer in the
division and Regulatory Services
um with with references URLs so you
could really get in if you really want
to understand it that information is
there
um
I think this is a good opportunity to
sort of summarize some of the stuff I've
heard already and really if you're going
to walk out of here
oh I didn't oh I'm sorry
I'm out Wyman I'm a division director
regulatory services
um
you could see here
the
the primary objective of regulatory
Services is is according to what is
written is marketing right so a lot of
people might think that's labels and and
so forth but really the focus that we
have in this is is associated with
safety it's it's safety for human
consumption safety for pet consumption
it's safety for commercial feed
um
and
you know I have 12
programs in this division that I oversee
uh fisma really belongs here but to
honestly just cannot handle it we're
trying to handle 12 programs with six
staff I only have five right now we're
trying to fill an open position it's
difficult uh but but we do I think have
somebody coming in
um and and before I get into this though
I really want to re-emphasize because
you guys are getting a lot of
information I'm just going to hit you
with a lot more right and I think the
biggest concern I see I've been in this
position for a little over a year I came
out of the private sector thing that
hits me hard and it hits me the most is
the I.T like I I worked a lot with with
with the you know some of the Des stuff
and and all that and I've worked in in
the Commonwealth of mass
we're using systems from the like like
it was said a fox Pro is developed in
84. we can't even find people to to
maintain it and and we're still putting
things I have 20 000 plus registrations
that I put in by hand and I have
somebody who does all day all they do is
separate out checks it that is from my
perspective that's the biggest
bottleneck right there so regardless of
what I say here and what you've heard my
point is to try to re-emphasize that
it's important I think we have a good
um relationship here hopefully running
into the future where we can assist each
other you guys can help push that and we
can help uh realize efficiencies across
the whole department not just animal
industry who has an RFP out there and
you should know in the back of the end
of that RFP are also requests for costs
and information associated with
upgrading other division I.T programs
which is a necessity so I just wanted to
push that and and I also wanted to say
in in this Division I have 12 programs
right it's overwhelming it's it's more
more than really what should be in one
Division and and I see working with Sean
and into the future whether we can break
these down into bureaus but the primary
thing I want to push here is that these
I I kind of break these down into three
sections because I think there's a
misunderstanding uh from from my
experience to date and and what exactly
um what regulatory Authority we have as
a division so we have these three
programs and if you include fisma our
federal programs for which we're sort of
a federal agents we act as federal
agents on on the fed's behalf so you'll
see in this uh in this slide here we'll
take the organic program as an example
they register us as a certifying agent
they license us we make decisions we
certify Farms we report directly back to
the USDA we don't report back to the
commissioner
um we don't report back to legislature
right we have an agreement with USDA who
authorizes us to do the work on their
behalf and so there's been a lot of
confusion on that when the when the feds
say we can and cannot do things
if by law I have to follow the federal
uh statements on that and that's that's
true of uh of the gap program it's true
of the country of origin program in fact
they tell us who to go inspect right the
feds tell us and then the food safety
modernization act I can't say a lot
about it's not in my Division I don't
understand it fully but I do understand
that it falls under those same sets
where again it's a federal programs
I also want to point out because I know
you guys deal with legislative bills
that come through here and and one of
the things I also want to push aside
from the I.T if I haven't said it again
the it is that uh
um when you guys make legislative uh
mandates it's great if you come to us
and ask us I'm noticing that because
um things get put I've noticed that
things have gotten put in the state rsas
that don't match other states right so
we may be one of all the states that
require something and and I get phone
calls from Purina let's say and say Al
what's going on here you guys have this
in your RSA I'm like yeah I know I said
well I can't change my whole
manufacturing line just to meet your
mandate hey man I so if you guys come
and talk to us before you make these
rsas it's extraordinarily helpful
because we can help you say okay this is
maybe the best way to achieve your
objective these are your objectives
we're mandated to do what you tell us
but it's easier for us to to do that if
if we're in communication before these
things you know are finalized and and I
say that because these National programs
um and I know you guys have been dealing
with some fertilizer issues we have
commercial feed commercial seed I think
might be coming through Horticulture
grade one biostimulants you know
um these are all all these programs in
the middle here are are based on
National
um legislative model bills that have
been presented from places like AFCO
ASCO
um you know what those organ in others
what those organizations are actually a
conglomeration if that's the right word
of state legislators uh division
directors all over the country
um technical experts I mean people
that's all they do risk characterization
of animals pet feed laboratory analyzes
the best in the country get together and
they they develop model plans that then
they give to all the states and they say
look this is the best we can come up
with and generally all the states that
degree in in the legislator uh
committees or bodies will adopt that but
if you throw something in there that
that hasn't been adopted on a national
level yet it can create a problem so I
just want to emphasize that we don't
want to make things more difficult for
our stakeholders that's you know
now the third section here is actually
the state the state rsas that you guys
have complete control over right and uh
the biggest one I think for us is to is
the seal equality program where and
these are voluntary a lot of these are
voluntary too so keep in mind if we go
out for instance and do an organic
inspection it's because somebody's asked
to come out and they want that Organic
certification it's completely voluntary
if they won't let us on their Farm or
they won't let us see something
that's their right but we can't give
them that certification it's you know so
so a lot of that stuff is is voluntary a
lot of this stuff like steel equality on
the state side is voluntary and what
that entails let's take Maple for
instance hey I want you to certify that
my maple product meets a certain
standard great we're going to have to go
through all your stuff you're gonna have
to be comfortable with us going through
your business plans things like that you
know some of this stuff gets
extraordinarily in depth
um some people aren't comfortable with
that and rightfully so maybe again
voluntary
um the one thing that's of Interest too
if I'm straight three or four of these
programs take all our time and and we're
reactionary to the rest of them all
right I'm dealing with five I have five
people anytime somebody goes out and
gives and does a higher level
enforcement I'm busy right three people
come in and say ah we just went out we
went to a local and this is what we
found
that takes up all my time and so it's so
it's a very difficult thing to to
maintain these programs and then jump to
the level of enforcement right where
it's necessary and on the federal level
I'm required to so somebody comes and
gives me that that's going to take my
time I'm gonna have to take time away
from some of these State programs and I
think you're going to find out with all
all of us where the staff issues where
we we try to integrate our programs as
best we can to meet the the what you
guys require us to do
um but it's it's a difficult thing to do
and I'm gonna say it again the greatest
way of efficiency I think for this
department is through it upgrades and
that's a real real thing and we need to
have uh legislative backing and money to
do that right we we can't
um
I just put this up here at department
environmental services because you know
you can see how their divisions kind of
broken up and they have bureaus and I
think certainly in my division would be
so it would be helpful if we were broken
up in into bureaus now the federal
program uh national account program I
kind of put some numbers here you could
see 80 producers what does that mean
well do you go out and visit 80 Farms
you spend 80 Days that's anybody wants
to go into that program again voluntary
we're going through their business plans
or going through their their um other
Horticultural plans where it's a very
in-depth uh view of of their business
right so it takes a lot of time takes a
lot of effort and then if we get uh as I
said before if we had some higher level
enforcement issues it really chews up a
lot of time
um good agricultural practices country
of origin labeling
um
oh this is interesting so and and I
bring up organic because of the recent
issues that that I've I've uh uh you
know associated with with the dropping
of livestock and so forth
um I have five people right now that
includes me this is this is what our
surrounding uh agents have it's 13 12 16
19 25 and that's really what it takes to
run a program like that
um we're down to crops and we'll see how
um
we had an audit where the feds came in
and said you guys are way understaffed
and that wasn't going to change so
uh the gap program again this is
microbial food safety is really what it
focuses on I I want to bring your
attention to that because because again
it's a marketing or marketing is our
directive but really a lot of what we do
and a lot of what we focus is on on
safety safety for for human consumption
safety for pet food safety for across
the board commercial feed
you certainly don't want to be getting
something to your your 100 cows and then
and then come home the next day and find
there's a problem right
um
you know some of the checklists that we
have to go through when we're doing
these inspections we have to do a couple
of a couple of inspections not just one
you know very time consuming I have one
person who is licensed by the federal
government to do this or just got a
second person license and he quit
because honestly the pay is better
elsewhere and that's that's a fair you
know I can't you can't blame anybody for
that we just got an authorization to
train a second person that's a 18 to 24
months is what's going to take to train
a second person uh but we'll we'll
manage it
you know I beat that one to death
National programs
uh feed fertilizer seed
what I want to point out here is is in
the feed in pet food program when that
started off I think I think I was told
of I think in
200456 fluctuated between four and five
thousand hey great we're gonna put this
in Excel at the time that was
now we're off to almost 20 000 and we're
still doing it by hand and and we it's
unsustainable and every time we make a
mistake and when we separate a check
right because we have to separate it
between two different funds the general
fund and a scale fund the two and the
five are right next to each other on the
computer now you hit one by accident
you've done a thousand of these in a day
uh trying to find that mistake going
back uh in in uh at the Comptroller's
office is is a nightmare right so all
this can be avoided Again by that up I.T
upgrade
uh
uh oh this is cool so
another thing we get a lot of phone
calls from small producers of pet food
products that don't want to pay the
registration fee like ah you know that's
not my call that's legislative call I
can't legally say you can't pay it when
somebody else has to right trying to
explain that but I want to explain to
you guys
a lot of the time it takes us to review
these is because of mistakes made from
the smaller manufacturers because they
don't have what Purina has experts
that's all they do right a small
manufacturer here in New Hampshire
they're trying to wing it you know
they're going through the rags they have
questions we help them as best we can
but um it takes a lot of time to review
that stuff that the people don't want to
pay for and the reality is
we have people trying to put stuff into
pet food all the time that is not
appropriate to be feeding a dog or a cat
in any way shape or form dangerous but
they're there and then we get we get the
car well I I I can eat it it's fine oh
my goodness well and so there's a lot of
time wasted in that as well where we
have to interact a lot with people
so it's not just that we're going out
there looking at labels going to retail
facilities we're actually doing a lot
that act alone generates a lot of
additional work and effort
um
some examples of registration of the
registration process what we're looking
at when somebody comes in they pay that
75 bucks and they they want that one pet
food label review this is what we're
reviewing we have medical claims we're
looking for unsafe ingredients the
nutritional values and the guaranteed
analysis have to be proven out we're
looking for misleading terms the label
formats the last thing we really that's
of importance to us although legally
because you've mandated it there's
certain things label formats we have to
follow through with and we do
uh the fertilizer sampling program came
online recently after being off for a
while because of you know staffing
issues and I just want to know when when
if if we get a lot of calls for people
who want sampling of fertilizer it's a
massive it it once one set of samples
results in a a long effort right so uh
every action has a reaction
these are some of the typical questions
we're looking at and this is what makes
it difficult to fill a position like
this is we need risk characterization
Specialists right we need people to
understand what chemicals are how they
interact in the body how they interact
in the past all that kind of stuff and
and we're starting them off at 40
something thousand so you know we deal
with it it's not uh it's not a point
here it's just not looking at labels
it's really getting into the safety of
the product that's being fed to your
animals
um
these are the state programs the
programs that you guys have complete
control over uh nutrient Management's a
great one we just got a complaint where
somebody jumped to an estimated five
tons of pumpkins right so we work with
the nhds on stuff like that because our
Authority uh we're authorized to go out
and do inspections uh at farms as the
first means so that we dealing we're
dealing with the pharmacy I think the es
but if sometimes it gets to a point
where it's beyond us we'll go straight
to Des or we don't get the response from
the farmer that's
required to fix the issue and then it's
a des regulations so we have to go
through them uh Farm commodities
uh oh the agricultural land protection
that's that's a good one it's it's uh we
go out and do inspections to make sure
that people are staying within the uh um
deed restrictions that are put on that
property that you guys paid for or the
taxpayers paid for uh and again when we
find a problem there it just results in
a whole nother thing of higher level
enforcement issues up time
the uh certified native Lumber you want
to actually extraordinary they do most
of that work we just sent out the
certificates God bless them
um
some of the uh if you
down here the procedures for our new
treatment management complaints in in
how one complaint can result in really
sometimes weeks if not months of
follow-up
um months
some of the farm Commodities that we we
do theoretically do inspections on
uh we do get we do get to
um
oh that's pretty neat
one of these things and what I've what
I've sort of uh emphasized already is a
lot of these things are voluntary so if
you're getting complaints from your
constituents you know before you come to
us it's it's important that you
understand a lot of the stuff you know I
don't want them coming onto my farm and
doing this as well it's a voluntary
program we don't have to that's your
choice but if you want that
certification this is what we have to do
to do it we never go
and do on it with gap on the federal we
have to do an unannounced inspections
and that's been agreed to beforehand but
I won't send my staff out to do
unannounced inspections anywhere at any
time uh it's just not safe people get
upset you know people don't want you on
their land and that's you know that's
their choice so we make phone calls now
and we make sure that they're you know
they know we're coming they're willing
uh some of the things we look for when
we're doing a seal of quality or
inspections it's it's it's not just
going out and looking at a piece of
fruit we're actually uh taking
measurements and doing all the stuff
and then on top of all that stuff we do
uh we judge agricultural Affairs we uh
well
I guess maybe I spoke to some of this
already the local labeling's interesting
UNH extension
uh
so we also have to get out all these
pamphlets signs uh we do we also do uh
clinics for hydrometer that that people
use for for Maple production uh we
produce guidelines there's a lot my
staff is never bored and there's there's
never need hey Al I need something to do
like Sean said we have exceptional
people working for us it's great and
uh I highlighted in red safety here
because although our dictate is
marketing really everything we're doing
is associated with safety
um
each of those 12 programs hats is its
own sets of laws rules state federal
sometimes we're getting into local law
as well and takes an amazing amount of
technical expertise that is specific to
each individual program so the people we
hire really have to know a lot and they
really have to absorb a lot all right
I'm giving you the hook because before
Josh won't have any time left all right
um
that's it see you later that's the last
one
those are us
thanks
I.T
good afternoon everybody thanks for
thank you
um I will be brief for time and um
because I just started in July I joined
the Department in July so for you
freshman Representatives I feel like
maybe a freshman State worker but so the
division of agricultural development is
a little different than what you've
heard previously from the other
departments where uh divisions where
they have a heavy regulatory or uh you
know on the safety end making sure that
the products are actually safe for use
our job is really to promote
um the farmers themselves and the
products to the consumers so we have a
two-fold mission
to help develop opportunities for the
New Hampshire producers Agricultural
Product producers to increase the
competitiveness competitiveness of them
economically and also to you know uh
get the value of Agriculture out to the
public to make sure that the consumers
in New Hampshire know how valuable and
what impact the food and products that
we create have in the state
um how do we do this
there's sort of two paths and and I'm
I'm glossing over there's a lot more
that we do but I wanted to focus on a
couple of issues today the grant
programs
um have a pretty huge impact and that's
mostly federal funds
um The Big E is um in West Springfield
Massachusetts the New Hampshire building
our division runs that and there's uh
that picture in the lower left is the
Big E this past September there's a 1.5
million attendees go through there in 17
days and they get to see 16 sorry 14
exhibitors that are New Hampshire made
products New Hampshire grown food and
there's always a line at the front door
it's it's amazing what people want and
our exhibitors then get calls later on
that say you know hey I was down at the
Big E I'm from Connecticut can you send
me some of that Maple brittle or
whatever so it exposes our producers to
new um
new new forms of uh income uh 17
demonstrators or entertainers that show
uniquely New Hampshire products or
musicians
um and then the photo on the right there
speaks to some of our informing the
public column the weekly Market Bulletin
our website and our directories and
marketing campaigns that's actually a
photo from an influencer who we worked
with travel and tourism to get a
Instagram campaign this year and there
was an influencer you know somebody who
has a ton of followers on Instagram that
can generate more uh you know Insight
than than we could
um and uh and they went around to three
or four different New Hampshire Farms
took pictures showed the products that
they had and shared them on our page as
well as their own which which kind of
double dipped for our our impact there
but I wanted to focus on the grants so
annually the things that we do every
year uh specialty crop block grant
that's a USDA program
the state Departments of Agriculture
receive money through these programs we
typically get between two and three
hundred thousand dollars a year for this
we have a project that we partner with
travel and tourism every year and then
the rest of the money is allocated to
other projects it's usually research or
promotion so a couple of examples you
can see there we just got done with
identifying cold hardy hydrangea
cultivars for Cut Flower production the
nursery industry is one of our biggest
industries money makers in the state so
identifying ways that New Hampshire
farmers can produce something that's
unique or you know more competitive than
say some you know their neighbors is
going to help us in the long run and
since 2019 we've got just under 1.5
million dollars in funding through that
Federal funding that we then disperse
back out into the community the
agricultural mini grants is something
that's within house up to a thousand
dollar matching Grant as funds allow
that's for promotion for New Hampshire
organizations like nonprofits Apple
Association Fruit Growers Association
maybe the Farm Bureau things like that
um and then we get into the one-time
grants these are new projects that have
developed over the last couple of years
that we're overseeing the farm and ranch
stress assistance Network
522 thousand dollars awarded to us
through USDA nifa which is the National
Institute of food and agriculture to
address the root causes of farmer stress
mental health and suicide we signed an
mou with UNH which obviously you've
heard through all of the divisions
they're a huge partner with us and they
really are that counter side with the
education and the Outreach that we don't
have as more of a regulatory department
and and they are funding Direct Services
which are really impressive
um you know individual family marriage
counseling Farm transition or estate
planning Tax Services things like that
you can learn a lot about that from the
UNH site and if you read some of our
Publications the local food purchase
assistance program nine hundred thousand
dollars that we partnered with the food
bank for a program that they give money
out to their 400 partner agencies they
also do some contract buying and some
bulk buying of food directly from New
Hampshire producers so that food you
know that the the whole Trail of the
receipts and the invoices and all that
stuff comes through to make sure that
that was purchased directly from a New
Hampshire farmer and it's kind of um you
know we get a double uh bang for our
buck where it goes to help the
underserved
um the on the the folks that are hungry
in in the state but it also that money
goes into Farmers Pockets you can see
some of the statistics there
we just got a local food for schools
Cooperative agreement another almost 600
000 again for purchasing directly from
Farmers but this is through school
districts so there are 44 school
districts that meet the threshold for a
certain amount of low and reduced lunch
um
folks that that subscribe to that
program they're going to get served
through this uh 25 000 students 300
small farms that are expected to benefit
and then one that we're really excited
about is the meat processing
infrastructure program this comes
through arpa funds it's a little over a
million dollars broken into two
different Pro projects uh 260
000 is going to develop a certificate
program we don't currently have one in
New Hampshire this is so that the
workforce can have some education before
they jump right into working at a meat
processing facility and that's going
through UNH and then we have 750 000 for
a grant program
for building capacity labor saving and
value added to those meat processing
facilities we expect that that will be
over subscribed there are four USDA
inspected meat processing facilities in
the state if they each ask for the
maximum award we're already over
subscribed and that's not talking about
third part already exempt in custom
butchers so if we can find some more
money for that that would be great and
you can see at the bottom that's a
little over uh four and a half million
dollars in funding that we've gotten
mostly from the federal government that
we've been able to get back into the
hands of farmers and producers and the
AG service providers that support them
real quick on the informing the public
part uh weekly Market Bulletin our
division puts that out started as market
news in 1917 and since 1923 it's been
published weekly ever since this is
where farmers get news
and the classifieds which they love
we're seeing a little dip in
subscriptions because there are more
places to get that whether it be
Facebook Marketplace or Craigslist or
things like that but we're certainly
looking at how we can build back our
subscription base we have a website
building on that I.T need we're redoing
the website right now we've talked to
some the folks over at doit some of the
other departments had had budgets to
have third parties come in and help them
rebuild their website we're taking this
on our own because we don't have that in
our budget and then we do social media
television radio marketing
um happy to speak to more of those
details
another another time
um we've got myself the division
director an information representative
who's part-time
um word word processors uh although I'd
like to get those titles changed one's
vacant there also our department
receptionist the other one works uh
extremely hard on the weekly Market
Bulletin publication design and right
now is currently updating our website
because the old website platform is no
longer supported and I cannot get a
license so you know that's those are
building on those I.T things that that
we really need to get fixed because we
can't carry out some of our duties and
those are those challenges is funding
and then staff if if we had a couple
other people somebody who focused solely
on grants
um you know another another program
assistant I think all of our divisions
could use help but we're still
accomplishing the things that you ask us
to do and and that's what I think is
really great about this department
and that's what I got
thank you very much appreciate your uh
presentation
commissioner Jasper
chairman I
I finished right on on time but
unfortunately we didn't leave any time
in the schedule for questions we're here
with your your pleasure
um if you want to take additional Time
Dr Crawford had an emergency had to to
leave for but um you know hopefully you
see the enthusiasm that the directors
all have that we all have for our
mission
um serving the people of the State of
New Hampshire and so
hard to keep the that enthusiasm down to
10 minutes uh that's what I was trying
to do but some of the directors are a
little bit more enthusiastic and and I
know they gave you a tremendous amount
of information and you know you've got
the handouts there we're all available
um to serve you of course you're our
primary committee and we want to uh to
be here to to help you better understand
what what we do and help you make sure
that you make the best decisions the
most informed decisions for the people
of the State of New Hampshire well we
thank you very very much for your time
um I know there are a few hands up so
we've got uh maybe a minute or two
go right ahead
um representative Sophie caitis
uh this is hard on the the dairy farm
support and I was just wondering how
they're doing
not terribly well for the most part and
you know I I was just looking at some
information
Nationwide again
that the number the production keeps
increasing Nationwide which pushes
the price of milk down because there is
an overproduction Nationwide
many of our farmers and I think if you
take
the four com the four governmental herds
out of it there's there are two herds at
UNH Grafton county is the last County
with a herd and Alvar in high school my
high school still has a small herd we're
right around 65 commercial Dairy herds
um many of them are facing
challenges with aging out
and there's no Next Generation the Farms
that are doing well and will survive are
the ones that have been Innovative and I
have been saying this long before I was
commissioner people have got to figure
out a way to Market directly
to the consumers and you've got a few
that are doing extremely well but
um
I've said this for probably
40 years Dairy Farmers are their own
worst enemies
because they every time when the milk
prices go down well we have to produce
more milk when the milk prices are up
well we have to produce more milk and
there isn't any type of
ability to really control that but our
challenges are a little bit different
because we have so few and so many next
Generations we will always have dairy
farms I suspect but they'll be the ones
that are bottling their own milk and and
selling
um directly and I and I hope some others
start figuring out a way to do that I
will continue to try to work to do that
I'm not I've not given up on New
Hampshire's own idea but the pandemic
put a real crimp into that and other
things have interceded but we will get
back to working on that idea and see if
we can do something to help thank you
question representative Bixby yes um so
a number of your department heads
mentioned things like we don't have the
resources for new measuring equipment or
new this or the new that I'm wondering
if that stuff has made it into your
budget request and if there's a way that
we as a committee can help push the
finance committee to um well and that's
quite frankly representative Bixby and
thank you for the question that's why we
were given Direction by the governor as
to what we could request with the
parameters and that's why you know for
um
you know our our actual needs without
being terribly greedy were
8.8 million but with the efficiency
budget it's 7.8 so there's a million
dollars of need there that hopefully we
will get
um and the same is is true going forth
into uh fiscal uh 25. so
you know certainly we're hopeful that
you can help us on that I'm also as I
say trying to be
realistic about what we can request the
way we develop the animal database is to
and I'm not an I.T guy so I'm just
saying we're leaving these doors open
so that eventually we can build the
rooms on where the doors are
without a great deal of additional
um cost these are the things we're
trying to do and I will tell you quite
honestly you know while I know we have
more person I'll need we're not going to
be adequately able to assess exactly
what those needs are until we get the it
systems that we need and I appreciate
your help
um in that in that process and we are we
are getting there oh
so um I'm so with the I.T I I put the
bill in I'm hoping that the amount that
you said you needed was actually as much
as you really needed
um and uh I don't know if that's coming
to this committee or if it's going to
Ways and Means or Finance it's that's
um
that one is they haven't sent the bill
out yet
um I'm wondering if there are other
uh items that
you are not able to fit into the budget
where some sort of legislation from this
committee May in fact uh help uh bridge
the gap or get things moving and I'm
hoping that it's obviously too late to
get new bills in this year but I'm
hoping that if something if things like
that come up that you will be able to
touch base with us and make sure that we
put in those requests for you I
appreciate that and we are working with
a number of house members and Senate
members on some of the statutory changes
we need and would like to see but there
are you know those challenges and
frankly one of the challenges we're
we're facing is space challenges Where
and if we get the Personnel we're going
to be chock-a-block full however uh Des
tells us we're going to be moving in May
within the same building but to a
temporary space and then someplace else
that's unacceptable and I've informed
the governor that the idea of
departments having to move twice
possibly three times is unacceptable
which shut us down for weeks at a time
so I'm trying to look at the possibility
of us moving over to the insurance
complex there is a lot of space there
where doj is going to I love being right
here but the reality is if they expect
us if we're expected to move several
times they're going to put us in a in a
hole that's going to take us a long time
to get out of we've the last time I
think the department moved was sometime
in the early 90s and I have been trying
to utilize the space as best at best we
can but we are bursting it at the seams
where
we are and so that's another thing that
I've had to be mindful of is how many
people can we put in this box that we're
we're currently in so
we're making great I'm proud of the
strides that we have have made and I
think we have been able to make the ones
that we have because we have been
realistic in what we've asked for I was
told on my first day on the job that the
department was constantly in triage I
really don't think we are in triage mode
all the time we're stressed but at least
uh yes uh one second I know that we had
scheduled uh Des to come in at 2 30. is
oh okay
um you can have them come in we'll have
one last quick question and I think we
got to wrap it up quick
and I'm glad to come back anyway thank
you madam chair uh we heard about a
couple of
um one-time Grant funded programs that
sounded really great local food purchase
assistance program that obviously is a
win-win the local food for schools
Cooperative agreement program so those
are one-time grants is are we looking is
there are there possible future federal
funds coming down the line are these
programs simply going to go away what
what are our hopes for the future of
these programs those are excellent
questions one of the things that I
talked to director Marshall about in
this and some of them do a go for a
couple of years and we never know what
the feds are going to put out there for
funding
but I I think it would be a real tragedy
if we developed these relationships and
then cut them off at the end of the
funding so we will be looking at ways
that we can can make these agreements
work going Beyond here because the food
is still going to be needed so what can
we do to make sure that even if there
isn't a large degree of a large amount
of federal money or maybe even you know
maybe we get to get some State money but
whatever we can do we want to see those
relationships continue because
you know it could be devastating if the
if Farmers have relied on those for a
couple of years and then we cut them off
like that that would could be the worst
thing that we could do so my goal is to
figure out a way to make them long-term
thank you commissioner Jasper I really
appreciate you and your staff for coming
in and taking the time we appreciate
your your educating us and keeping us
apprised of all the programs and work
and diligence that you have all put
through so we we look forward to seeing
you and hearings and and hearing from
you uh and other times thank you so much
for your presence thank you we
appreciate you being our audience today
we get to tell our story and we don't
get to do that I think often enough and
I think we have a great story to tell so
thank you very much
so next up um we have the Department of
Environmental Services I believe Ms
Sarah U.S Kern is here oh there you are
okay
um
does anybody need to take a quick break
are you are you just setting you're
setting up your stuff and
yeah we're gonna we're gonna take like a
a two minute break so people can
yeah you should
I hope it's right
so we'll be with you momentarily
oh yeah it's got 300 and 326.
that's right that's right yeah she put
foreign
okay I think we can uh we can proceed
good afternoon Madam chair and members
of the committee and thank you so much
for inviting us here to talk about des
and specifically the waste management
division
first we have our commissioner
good afternoon again I'm Bob Scott
commissioner with Department of
Environmental Services uh I just want to
do a quick Cameo uh introduce so you can
see some faces anyways not that we have
great faces but uh and and point out our
senior leadership team so we've also
brought Mark Sanborn he's our assistant
commissioner uh the uh you're probably
aware that the waste management division
director is uh
indisposed so uh you're getting Sarah
your house Kern our assistant director
uh our Water Division director Randy
Pelletier is somewhere behind me
is he waving okay and our our air
Resources Division director Craig Wright
is here also so there he is okay so uh
just really quickly I just want to make
myself available to you all I was gonna
I say a cameo I was gonna walk out the
door in a few minutes unless somebody
wants to talk to me but I'm available
anytime if anybody would like to talk
I'll I'll say generally for the agency
are
some of the things that are taking up a
lot of our time right now are moving we
have a lot of funding between arpa funds
for the state we had 185 million dollars
moved to us for uh water Wastewater and
Dam projects uh the bill infrastructure
uh law moved a lot of money to us over
the next five years so we have
unprecedented amounts of uh work and the
good news is money for the local
communities for water and wastewater
systems that that takes a lot of our
time and will as we move forward uh and
obviously uh nobody can read the
newspaper without hearing about
different forms of water contamination
so those are really among the the normal
day-to-day things which you'll hear a
lot about today those are things of late
taking up a lot of the agency's time and
and focus so with that unless there's
questions from me I will uh I'll leave
you to the good hands of the waste
management division but uh Madam chair I
don't know if you had any anything for
from the
the uh the committee no um well
representative
thank you madam chair thank you director
for taking my question
um you mentioned that there was money
for the uh for dams in the state I was
wondering specifically about Silver Lake
if you had any funding for that are you
working on that in conjunction with the
County Commissioners at Belknap sure we
have been in contact with the County
Commissioners I know for for Silver Lake
which is Downstream actually there's
more than one Silver Lake in the state
which I find interesting uh which is
Downstream of uh our Lakeport Dam uh
which is at the uh near Lake arabesaki
uh that's a an area where we've had some
issues with the property owners on the
uh on the
the water body if you will and and it's
somewhat hard to control depending on
the with flooding so uh the County
Commissioners have some money they were
they've been talking about moving uh to
do a study uh there's been a there was a
study done I think in the 1980s I think
by the Army Corps of Engineers that
would all have to be redone so I'm not
sure where they are the last feel I got
from them is that they weren't inclined
to move ahead but that's the discussion
between you know the people there uh
ma'am
go ahead uh yes
um I know that there were discussions
with Des back as far as 2012 when the
constituency of that uh late came to Des
and that this has been an ongoing issue
um and for the county to take it solely
on
um when like I said it's been going on
for almost a decade uh with Des I'm just
wondering uh if for some reason we don't
do the study what will Des do
uh short answer is is nothing so so
there's enabling enabling Bill allowing
for Dam to be built and money to be
appropriated without appropriating money
as you're aware so the steps to be
taking for this or any other Dam like
that would be a study to be done and
I'll be very clear that it's not an easy
thing because in order for that Dam to
be built over a mile and a half for the
Winnipesaukee River would have to be
dredged and then periodically dredged as
it back you know the silts in and that
that in itself I'm not sure would be
approval but the Army Corps of Engineers
but assuming all that the study would
need to be put in place and then
to this body for the capital budget
moving forward somebody has to put in
for that money to be done for the the
capital project of building the dam
doing the dredging so that would be a
multi-step process none of that will
happen without the first step of that
study
thank you very much appreciate it you're
welcome
hey I appreciate you dropping in and uh
and parachuting in and giving us a a
your greetings
um so I
say go ahead the rest of the program
thank you so much appreciate it you're
thank you
I'm Sarah you house Kern I know that's a
mouthful so you're always welcome to
just call me Sarah Curran and that's
totally fine and easier
I'm here with the five Bureau
administrators from the waste management
Division and what I thought I would do
is give you a brief overview of how our
division is organized and our primary
responsibilities and then we'll have a
presentation from each of our Bureau
administrators and so that they can give
you more details on the programs of
their bureaus we also have another
colleague from Des here with us today
Anthony druin from the biosolids program
Anthony could you wave
the biosolids program actually resides
in our Water Division not the waste
management division but we know that
bills from that program tend to come
before your committee so we wanted to
give you a chance to meet Anthony as
well he will does not have a
presentation prepared for today but he
can certainly answer questions at the
end and also is happy to to meet
everyone
we have worked in time for questions at
the end of our presentation so if it
would please the chair and the committee
I suggest that we hold questions until
after all the bureau administrators have
spoken about their programs
thank you so the waste management
division is organized into five bureaus
we have the oil remediation and
compliance Bureau which focuses on
proper management of petroleum products
to prevent them from being released into
the environment
they do emergency response when spills
occur and they oversee longer term
investigation and Remediation of
petroleum-contaminated sites where where
larger or longer term spills have
happened
they also have programs to provide
financial assistance for cleaning up
petroleum contamination
we also have a hazardous waste
remediation Bureau and they focus on
cleaning up properties that have been
contaminated with hazardous waste and
emerging contaminants and our
brownfields program which revitalizes
underutilized contaminated properties to
bring them back into productive use also
resides within our hazardous waste
remediation Bureau
our hazardous waste management and Solid
Waste Management bureaus they do similar
things they both help to ensure the
proper management of hazardous waste and
solid waste by providing training to the
folks who handle those types of waste by
providing technical assistance
compliance assurance and permitting
and our mtbe remediation Bureau is our
fifth Bureau and what they do is a lot
more than mtbe remediation actually the
mtbe remediation Bureau focuses on
um providing remedies for contaminated
water supplies and specifically water
supplies that are contaminated by mtbe
and perfluorinated contamination
and our drinking water and groundwater
trust fund program and our pfas response
program both reside within the mtbe
remediation Bureau
so all of the work that we do is all
about protecting human health and the
environment through all the programs
that I briefly described to you we
wanted to include a slide that shows our
primary responsibilities but I touched
on those already and our Bureau
administrators are going to be providing
more detail on them so I think we'll
just get started with the bureau
administrators so first we have Bob
Bishop from the oil remediation and
good afternoon my name is Bob Bishop I'm
the administrator of the oil remediation
and compliance Bureau and we are
everything petroleum within the state
all right we have different sections
within the bureau that really worked
together
the UST and AST permitting regulates the
storage of petroleum and for underground
storage tanks also other hazardous
substances
that strives to keep the the materials
in contained in good shape and really
being a good Steward of the materials
accidents happen they do get out at
times or they have in the past before we
had a strong program to regulate the
storage of of these items
and then our spill response program
comes into play so we we have one
program designed to keep it locked up
another program to react and to respond
to the spills to ensure that we protect
human health and the environment and
have the get those spills cleaned up
we then have petroleum spill
investigation and Remediation program
petroleum remediation section and so
when that spill does happen and if
there's any residual that needs to be
addressed that program addresses those
residual petroleum contaminants
and then we also have the oil discharge
and Disposal cleanup fund and this is an
excess Insurance Fund that assists those
who have had spills with having them
cleaned up appropriately
I'll go through each section
individually
and starting here with our spoon
response and complaint investigation
section we respond to about 300 spills
per year and these spills are from a
whole host of different categories
probably half of them are Transportation
related about 150 of them a year
um 90 to 100 come from
tank systems uh the majority of those
are home heating oil tank systems so
those tank systems that are regulated
under our compliance program
we really don't see releases from those
our program is on call 24 hours a day
seven days a week 365 days a year they
are called into action almost almost
every day to go respond to a spill
primarily the spills are petroleum
spills but 95 then we have some other
hazardous materials or even uh
other materials that wouldn't be
hazardous materials like milk that can
cause a big problem when a tanker truck
rolls over and Spills its spills the
milk into a ditch and it turns into a
yogurt and that's not very good for the
environment either
you can see in these photos here the
photo on the left is from a home heating
oil spill it's dyed red that is home
heating oil and then on the right is a
photo from one of our Coastal facilities
and primarily what you're seeing there
is the eversource power plant facility
but along the piscata core River the
scottoqua river we have over 100 million
gallons of petroleum petroleum storage
so it's a real Focus for us in the
coastal region to respond to spills and
to be prepared in case the spill happens
along the river and that leads into the
Great Bay Estuary which is is a very
sensitive environmental resource and
we're well aware of that and we take a
lot of steps to protect that resource
and to protect the River Community
uh that involves partnering with other
agencies we partner with the Coast Guard
we partner with Maine dep uh the the
Naval Yard we have numerous agreements
with them in order to be able to respond
effectively and quickly to any emergency
that happens in that region
the section that does spill response
also investigates complaints and these
are complaints of disposal of materials
spilled materials whether they are
hazardous material hazardous waste Solid
Waste or petroleum spills and they do
about 40 to 60 complaint investigations
a year
our hazardous waste management Bureau
and our Solid Waste Management Bureau
are primarily responsible
for the
compliance at facilities that are
designed to manage those materials so
these complaints are at facilities that
are not designed or at locations not
designed to manage those materials
kind of illegal dumping if you think of
it that way
or oil compliance section this is our
com our section that regulates storage
tanks above ground storage tanks and
underground storage tanks for
underground storage tanks we have a
specific statute that provides the
regulatory Authority and this is for
hazardous substances and petroleum
we have about 40 million gallons of
materials stored in underground storage
tanks in New Hampshire
above ground storage tanks that number
is about 156 million so we're looking at
close to 200 million gallons of
petroleum primarily petroleum products
stored in regulated systems within New
Hampshire earlier I mentioned the home
heating oil tanks we don't regulate
the work of the oil compliance section
for underground storage tanks it's
petroleum and hazardous materials they
inspect those tanks every three years
they also that section reviews designs
of of new systems and systems that are
being upgraded or substantially modified
we did 44 design reviews in the last
calendar year
we also do construction inspection so
any facility that is going through that
design review process gets inspected
before it
stores these materials
this program is what we call EPA
authorized so it actually works in lieu
of the EPA program and the EPA
regulations they've authorized the state
of New Hampshire to regulate underground
storage tanks
we have an operator certification
program as well that is designed to
provide training to those operators of
underground storage tanks above ground
storage tanks those are regulated under
a different statute it's the same
statute that applies to our oil spills
and this is a very similar system where
we do inspections of the above ground
storage tanks and we have design review
that happens last year there were 18
plans for new installations that were
submitted and reviewed and with those
plans we also do construction
inspections before those go into into
operation
mentioned the
section that addresses oil spills and
these are for the more long term so this
is after emergency response has occurred
and this section does investigation of
spills the remediation and the long-term
monitoring of groundwater that's been
impacted by those spills
we have about 1100 active sites
currently that we are managing looking
and actively remediating cleaning up
monitoring to see the natural decay of
any contaminants that may be in that
groundwater we really focus on human
health and Water Resources so the
groundwater is is of particular concern
within this program last year this
program at 131 sites that were closed
there were 90 new sites that came in as
I mentioned before 84 of those were from
those home heating oil tanks so those
tanks that we are actually regulating
through our above ground and underground
storage tank system or compliance
section those tanks we haven't been
seeing releases from uh those tanks have
been in good shape going back to the 80s
when we required double walled system in
the early 90s when the piping had to be
and then finally we have our fund
management section and this section
oversees the oil disposal and discharge
fund I mentioned at the beginning this
is an excess Insurance Fund so this fund
provides money Beyond Insurance when
either insurance has run out or
insurance is not in place to help pay
for the cleanup of these petroleum
contaminated sites
many of the sites are are older Legacy
sites that we've been dealing with for a
while from that previous generation of
tank systems that was in place with
throughout the state
this fund is available strictly for
corrective action so that is the removal
of soil removal of contaminants treating
of the groundwater and the continued
monitoring of groundwater
it has funded over 4 000 cleanups since
its Inception and over 3 300 of those
cleanups are complete at this time since
1988.
this also provides Financial Assurance
which is part of the federal
requirements for underground storage
tank systems that they have Financial
Assurance so that say your gas station
that goes into the corner they have to
have
a
mechanism in order to be able to clean
up any spill that may happen
along with this it supports what we call
our safe tank program this program
provides home heating oil tanks to lower
income
citizens within New Hampshire it's a
method that we have to try to address
the home heating oil issue to get to
those tanks before they release and
replace them if with new tanks in
situations where
individuals may not have the means to do
I think that's my last slide and I'll
take questions at the end of the full
presentation thank you thanks Bob and
next we have Jeffrey Martz the
administrator of the Hazardous Waste
thank you madam chair members of the
committee for having us today uh as
Sarah mentioned my name is Jeff Martz
I'm the administrator the Hazardous
Waste remediation Bureau and our Bureau
has uh oversight of investigation and
Remediation of hazardous waste sites so
that that mainly includes all of the
contamination besides petroleum that has
gotten into soil and groundwater my
Bureau is divided into two sections we
have state site section in our federal
sites section and the federal site
section has two subsections that include
super fund and Department of Defense
sites and our Bureau has about 24 staff
members most of which are engineers and
hydrogeologists many of whom have
professional certifications in their
respective fields
our state light our state lead section
has 14 positions that manage
collectively about 800 sites located
across the state and they're
investigating uh
overseeing remedial action and
monitoring long-term monitoring
amenities sites where groundwater can
remains contaminated
the breakdown of sites includes about
612 hazardous waste sites 180 solid
um closed landfills that are unlined and
then there are six Active landfills in
the state that are managed by the state
site section and our section is divided
up into three subsections which include
the emerging contaminant group and five
staff in this group mainly focus on
emerging contaminants such as pfas so
for example the saint Cobain site
investigation is managed by one of the
staff members in the emerging
contaminant
group now it's important to note that a
lot of our sites cross over between
these groups so we have sort of some
fluid lines between them but the
emerging contaminant group has expertise
and continual professional development
in the field of emerging contaminants
because there's a lot of new science
constantly coming out on this topic
next we have our brownfields program
consisting of three staff and the main
goal there is to obtain funding to
transform underutilized properties back
into beneficial use and I'll talk a
little more about that on the next slide
and then we have our groundwater
remediation and permanent Group which
consists of five staff that primarily
focus on landfills both the active and
inactive as well as the release
detection monitoring so if you had a
lined Lagoon we require certain
monitoring activities to make sure that
that liner is operating properly and not
contaminating groundwater
so I just want to highlight some of the
recent activity in our brownfields
program so our brownfields cleanup Grant
competition is about to award two
hundred thousand dollars to the Bri
Development LLC for cleanup work at the
Sinclair Hotel Site in Bethlehem and
then we have a two hundred thousand
dollar award for the city of Franklin
for cleanup work at the Stanley Mill
site in Franklin
and HDs was recently awarded 2 million
EPA Brownfield assessment grant for a
five-year period so that's a significant
influx of money for brownfields and
we're also awaiting final word on a 790
000 EPA Brownfield State response
program grant for 2023 pursuant to the
so now I'm switching from our state
sites to the federal state section and
specifically in Superfund we have five
staff members that work on 22 New
Hampshire Superfund sites these sites
are managed in conjunction with the U.S
EPA and they're divided into two groups
we have uh fund lead sites which receive
funding primarily from either the EPA or
the state and then there are PRP or
potentially responsible party-led sites
where the polluter is paying directly
for investigation and cleanup of those
types of sites so by the Numbers we have
eight fund lead sites in the state 11
PRP or potentially responsible party
sites one combination PRP and fund lead
which is the Savage well 1D listed site
which is the Londonderry Town garage and
one proposed for listing which is the
also in our federal sites section is the
Department of Defense sites where we
have two positions that address six DOD
or Department of Defense sites but don't
let the numbers fool you uh one of those
sites includes the peas trade Port that
has over 100 individual uh areas of
concern that are being addressed so
essentially 100 individual sites at peas
and and some of those sites are are
quite significant
and finally there are 25 thuds or
formally used defense sites so these
could include everything from the peas
trade port to Revolutionary War musket
Fields where musket drills were held so
it really kind of spans the gamut in a
lot of interesting history
but just want to include those uh for
reference
and with that I'll pass it on to Matt
Taylor
Matt Taylor's the administrator of our
thank you very much yes my name is Matt
Taylor and I am the minister of the MTB
remediation Bureau we have three basic
main uh sections within the group we
have what is our uh MTB settlement funds
our drinking water
um the drinking water and groundwater
trust fund and then our pfas response
under our MTB of settlement funds we do
uh sampling of drinking water within the
state since 2014 we have sampled over 12
000 private residents homes
um
well we also do site investigation and
Remediation primarily that has been
Source removal and water line extensions
the drinking water groundwater trust
fund Administration is uh separate from
the MTB settlement funds
that concentrates on the protection
preservation enhancement of drinking
water and groundwater resources in the
state there is a 19-member advisory
commission where we take old proposals
to them for decision making in 2022 we
funded 23 drinking water infrastructure
projects totaling about 8.8 million in
Grants 9.7 million in loans
we also had six Source water protection
projects Source water protection is when
we provide funding so they can purchase
land that is around a Wellhead to
provide a buffer so there was 1.5
million in Grants protecting 370 acres
of land
and finally we have our pfas response
which is coordinated by Amy Russo this
uh is the study investigation and
testing for contamination caused by the
plural ordinated chemicals Miss Riso is
the point of contact much of this study
and research is done by other divisions
bureaus and so forth but she Remains the
point of contact for the Department
also uh within that section we have the
pfas rebate program this is a rebate
program for private homeowners this
provides five thousand dollars for a
treatment system at the home or ten
thousand dollars for a connection to an
existing water line the perfect
reference is to have a water line so we
also have the pfas loan and grant
program which provides funding for the
thank you Matt
and next we have Leah McKenna the
administrator of our Solid Waste
good afternoon Madam chair members of
the committee my name is Leah McKenna
and I am the administrator of the solid
waste management Bureau and excited to
spend just a couple of minutes with you
today to talk about what our program
does
so on the first slide well let me back
up in the last couple of years
um we've probably picked up a paper or
read one of the online articles dealing
with Solid Waste Management the topic is
definitely been on the in the Forefront
of news media and the general public and
the legislature so after a prolonged
period of time where the program was
very very very resource deficient we
were able to achieve a bit of a
reorganization of the program and the
addition of two uh new positions
in the last year we have mostly filled
the positions in the bureau we're proud
to say that we have uh 16 16 folks in
our Bureau and I'll go into uh sort of
how our Bureau is is laid out so we have
four sections within the bureau our
first listed is the engineering and
permitting section and they are
responsible for permitting Solid Waste
facilities
they deal with compliance of active
facilities ensuring that they are
submitting all the reports on time that
they need to submit and they work with
applicants to ensure that the submittals
for applications for for new facilities
contain all the information that are
required in order for our department to
make decisions on permitting those
facilities
next we have the compliance Assurance
section
so the engineering and permitting
section we have five staff in compliance
Assurance also has five staff we are
currently building a uh an inspection
program whereby we enter and inspect
Solid Waste facilities and ensure
compliance with the multitude of rules
in the statute that oversees our program
they we also an arm of that section
assists Us in rule writing and conducts
enforcement actions when warranted
next we have the reporting information
financial management section a strong
section of one and a half and they are
responsible for managing a small number
of grants that are
um are doled out to a couple of uh
landfills and incinerators that are
going through closure activities
um lastly and and uh and newestly we
have the materials management education
and planning section and as I mentioned
during the reorg the reorganization of
the program we added a couple of new
staff but we also added a new program
and it's our planning program the solid
waste management Bureau has not had a
planning arm in well over a decade and
so we're very pleased to um to have
three folks in that in that section and
we have Mike Nork here with us and he is
the administrator of that materials
management education and planning
section and we thought there might be
questions for for him so so he's here
um all right
so we are um our program is duly
authorized under the RSA 149m the solid
waste management statute
um
and we wanted to just sort of lay the
groundwork of what solid waste is and
some of the the definition of solid
waste is just as important of what it
isn't as what it is
um and so the definition of Statute of
of solid waste does not include
hazardous waste or yard waste bodies of
deceased persons nuclear and nuclear
waste and septage and all the items on
so in New Hampshire there are 270 give
or take operating facilities and we
split those into three different
categories we have collection storage
and transfer facilities such as you know
your town transfer station
um we have processing and treatment
facilities composting facilities and
incinerators would be examples of those
and then we have landfills which Jeff
alluded to there are six major landfills
in New Hampshire I'll go into a little
bit of detail on those in an upcoming
slide
so in addition we have a total of about
600 inactive or closed facilities in New
Hampshire fairly evenly split between
asbestos disposal sites and those are
sites known to have been contaminated by
asbestos material that stemmed from the
Johns Manville site in Nashua so those
are between the cities of Nashua and
Hudson
Town Hudson and um 300 Town dumps we
would call your your Old Town Town dumps
um
so last slide some of us are kind of
numbers junkies so I wanted to provide
some information regarding
um disposal of waste in New Hampshire
and where that goes and and to whom
these facilities are required to submit
reports to us on an annual basis
detailing the solid waste that they take
in
and the types of solid waste that
they're permitted to
this data is from the 2020 reports
and we've split that into limited
service area landfills and unlimited
service area basically all that means is
a limited service area they are only
permitted to take waste from a limited
service area on unlimited they're
allowed to to take waste from anywhere
uh we also have one waste energy
facility and that would be Wheelabrator
in Concord let me back up the three
limited service area landfills would be
Nashua Four Hills in Nashua the Lebanon
landfill and the lower Mount Washington
Valley landfill in Conway
and then the unlimited service area
landfills are Mount Carberry in success
nces in Bethlehem and tlr3 TurnKey
landfill in Rochester
so thank you for your time and we look
forward to engaging with you in the
last but not least we have Todd
piskovitz the administrator of the
thank you madam chairperson and members
of the committee my name is Todd
piskovitz I'm the administrator of the
Hazardous Waste Management Bureau so the
resource conservation and Recovery Act
or request establishes Federal
requirements for the management of
hazardous waste and provides for federal
authorization of State programs that are
at least as stringent as the federal
program
similar to the UST program Des has been
authorized by EPA to implement requ in
New Hampshire and we currently receive
approximately 522 thousand dollars
annually to implement the program
the Hazardous Waste Management Bureau is
the arm of Des designated to assure
compliance with request we do that
through compliance and enforcement
training and Outreach information
management and technical assistance
we're a 15-person bureau
divided into five sections thank you
and it starts with drafting hazardous
waste rules that align with the epa's
regulations and oftentimes is is more
stringent and then shepherding those
Draft rules through the rulemaking
process we're also responsible for
regulate regularly updating our EPA
authorization and once authorized the
program the state program is enforceable
in lieu of the federal program
there are over 2 000 generators of
hazardous waste in the state and those
that generate more than 220 pounds of
hazardous waste per month which is about
300 facilities are required to attend
annual hazardous waste training and to
maintain at least one stat Des certified
staff
those that generate less than 220 pounds
of hazardous waste per month are
required to self-certify every three
years that they're complying with the
regulations our staff provides about 25
one to two day hazardous waste training
we also provide engineering support and
we review and process applications for
all hazardous waste permits there
currently aren't any tsdfs in New
Hampshire there is one 10-day Transfer
Facility that's in Newington but we also
issue 10 to 15 limited permits annually
these allow for The Limited treatment of
hazardous waste by generators at their
facility and their function is to reduce
the volume of hazardous waste that
requires off-site disposal there are
currently 63 facilities in New Hampshire
with active limited permits
to assess compliance at facilities we
conduct inspections of hazardous waste
and and compare what they're doing with
the Hazardous Waste or used oil
regulations
we strive to enforce the rules in a
consistent manner this year we plan to
complete full compliance inspections of
16 large quantity generators and 16
others that's with three inspectors the
EPA also has inspection Authority and
they'll do a couple of inspections a
year as well
finally a reporting and information
section tracks activity and
transportation of hazardous waste last
year more than 2 000 facilities in New
Hampshire generated more than 11 and a
half million pounds of hazardous waste
that they shipped off site for treatment
disposal and Recycling and our program
is there to help ensure that those 11
million pounds are handled properly and
don't make their way into the
environment
thank you
thanks Todd
that concludes the information that we
have prepared for you and we do have
time for questions I can call up any one
thank you very much appreciate it uh
any questions from our committee
uh representative datsey
uh yes can you tell us how you dispose
and where you dispose of contaminated
soil
sure uh Jack or Bob would you like to
Jeff
so contaminated soil generally has to be
characterized for transport to off-site
disposal facilities
um so in some cases it's considered
solid waste and it might be disposed of
as a in a landfill in other cases it may
be hazardous waste there might be
managed at a hazardous waste facility
but you know characterizing that soil is
kind of the key in understanding what
contaminants are present and how that
needs to be managed
foreign
representative Murray
thank you madam chair for taking my
[Music]
Anthony Drew in but maybe not um my
question was around delisting of
Superfund sites how does a d-listed how
does a Superfund Site become delisted
good question and that's actually Jeff
so basically it has to go through a
process of being determined to
substantially comply with des and EPA
rules
um the one that happened for the
Londonderry Town garage happened a
number of years ago so you know frankly
I think our other sites are are not in a
position to be delisted because they all
have you know substantial environmental
issues that are being worked through or
managed
um so you know as far as the nuts and
bolts it basically has to you know be
substantially clean to uh to go through
that process
thank you
representative Bixby
so this question this question is for
Anthony drouin uh so
um last term we did a bill in this
committee that uh
dealt with establishing uh soil pfas
levels and uh
the and I was wondering uh part of that
was contingent on the results of the
USGS study of
um pfas and
um
and I was wondering uh what Pro where is
that in
what progress has been made on that
where are we look what are we looking at
in terms of uh what the background pfas
levels are in soils and what would then
count as further contaminated
so great I know uh Anthony
and I are both working on that project
and involved several components so
um the USGS has been working with Des to
study pfas occurrence in Shallow soil
around the state so as part of that work
they collected approximately a hundred
uh or samples from 100 locations around
the state uh somewhat randomly selected
based on areas that had limited
disturbance so we're targeting forested
areas places that hadn't been developed
and that data has been published and
made available to the public through a
USGS data release site so that was our
task one of this USGS study task two was
a series of bench experiments to
evaluate how pfas Leech from New
Hampshire specific soil so we different
we identified approximately five
different soil types that are
characteristic of soils found around the
State and we collected soil samples
they've been uh
had various amounts of pfas added to
them and a series of experiments have
been done to evaluate what parameters
affect leaching because there's
different factors that can influence
that leech ability such as pH we even
looked at protein and essentially the
results of that study are anticipated to
be released about the end of January but
I'll just copy out that's dependent upon
the last few samples getting through
laboratory analysis our labs are very
backed up right now with the number of
pfas samples so it it might be a little
bit later than the end of January but
we're anticipating that very soon and
then the third component was a field
study looking at two specific sites one
was an a triple F site where we have
contamination and the USGS did some
detailed soil evaluations groundwater
evaluations and what we call poor water
sampling using lysimeters so that's
measuring water as it percolates through
the soil column but hasn't quite reached
the water table and that that data
really should be happening about the end
of January so sort of circling back to
where we are on uh direct contact
screening values we've assembled a
committee in uh the Hazardous Waste
remediation Bureau that has hired a
outside contractor for technical support
on uh modeling uh pfas leachability and
soil so we're going to be using that
contractor to take the data that's going
to be forthcoming from the USGS and
looking at the most appropriate models
that are available this is an area of
again rapidly evolving science which is
why we've reached out to uh you know
experts in in the field and we've
assembled our internal team of experts
to evaluate that data and our our goal
is to comply with the RSA that was
passed that requires initiation of rule
making by November of this year
okay
um first I have a question too and I'll
get to you I
oh go ahead I'm sorry yeah so
um did it uh what in the those
undisturbed sites what sort of presence
of pfas were you finding in in those
sites
so pfas was detected in every single one
of those sites there was some level of
pfas found
um
you know that there was generally less
than about a part per billion and if
you're familiar with pfas and analytical
capabilities most Laboratories most
commercial Laboratories can't detect
below a part per billion so we worked
with a laboratory to really sort of push
the limits of analytical capabilities to
get down below a part per building
because there were studies uh from
across the country that that suggests
there may be lower lower concentrations
and indeed once we sent these samples
off to Laboratories we were finding you
know generally less than a part per
billion for individual pfas uh chemicals
so so generally every single sample had
at least one pfas detected and um
another part of the story is we've gone
back to to resample some of the ones uh
some of the sites that had slightly
elevated uh pfas and I think by elevated
I'm talking about maybe as high as six
parts per billion in contrast at some
waste sites we are seeing hundreds of
parts per billion uh so just to put in
perspective
um so the results of that resampling
should also be coming out uh end of
January time frame
okay um I my question is do we ever have
any instances of contamination happening
from a bordering state or even Canada
well you know I think as we you know
we're starting to evaluate
um
these data in the context of Regional
Air patterns uh because you know there
have been studies that that found pfas
in in polar bear blood so you know I
think there is a component to
large-scale transport you know I've
talked to uh the folks in our air
division who have looked at acid rain
and and sort of the Regional Air pattern
so you know that that's something I
think we're going to consider but you
know I think there is a component of
long-range transport exactly what that
is you know we're still in the very
early stages of you know considering I
think there's a lot to look at uh with
with these data thank you you have a
question over here representative Howard
thank you madam chairman
um I I noticed on I think this question
is for Ms McKenna
um I noticed that where it said what is
solid waste and solid waste equals
um and then in the next paragraph
sideways does not equal
um hazardous waste and yet in the
paragraph above it lists asbestos
infectious waste and bulky waste so how
is it that those are broken out to be
not not um hazardous waste
so by by definition those items so bulky
waste examples
um like appliances appliances well
that's white goods but potentially
um and those would be free of of any
sort of refrigerants so so we aren't
talking about white goods that would
have a hazardous waste component to them
and how about Asbestos and infectious
waste is there is that broken out into a
separate
place or they are solid waste there's
Solid Waste without being hazardous
waste they are solid waste without being
hazardous waste that's interesting yeah
that's yeah it's statutory definition of
I see yeah I see okay thank you yeah
sure
Todd has a follow-up representative oh
excuse me so by statutory definition in
order to be a hazardous waste it either
has to have one of four category uh
characteristics either ignitable toxic
and by toxic it has to fail a certain
test
um
corrosive it has to be corrosive
why am I not
and reactive so thank you thank you from
the audience
um
or it has to be listed and there's a
list of several hundred chemicals and
asbestos is a separate category and
those other things are separate
categories so there is a statutory
definition of what has situation so are
these things static in a way that those
other it sounds like those other
characters that are Dynamic and and
interactive with things and and things
like infectious waste and asbestos are
static in the in the waste stream well
it's not that it's stat it's it's that
they don't they just don't meet the
definition like for instance you you'd
probably think
asbestos would be toxic but there isn't
in terms of the toxicity definition but
there is not a a toxicity test for that
so it's it's a separate category so in
order to be considered toxic it has to
fail what's called a toxicity
characteristic leaching procedure test
and there's a a list of tests that EPA
has developed that
that a chemical or a constituent has to
fail in order to be considered toxic
okay one more quick question from
representative Denzel you had a question
so I think this is for
um Cheryl Bondi it it's concerning MTB
as well as pfas questions so
for several years I worked for a water
water purification company as well as a
well driller and then had my own
huge system at our home and so I I
followed everything for a while from the
time that Hassan was leaving office with
that big huge settlement with Exxon and
the state you know put together a
website and and was um trying to be
transparent as well as every I followed
everything that had to do with Saint
Cobain many people were were literally
drinking poisoned water for a year and a
half and still had nothing
um done so where is all that and where's
all that money are there still those
transparency websites and are we because
last I knew there was still problems
going on at Saint gobane and they're
still running operations as normal so
this is a very big question but as much
as you could give me I'd really like to
know
um yeah so when we're talking about
seeing go bam we have a responsible
party so I'm actually going to let Jeff
take your question but to just back up
for a moment so people know so the MTV
settlement we uh the state went in a
lawsuit against 16 Distributors of fuel
uh 15 of them settled that was the 82
million that we have been spending that
has to be only spent on MTB remedia sure
the one that didn't set up we went to
court that was where we got the 276
million and that's the groundwater trust
fund
it's
yeah so to give you a little bit of an
update on on cincobain so uh cincobain
was and for those of you who might not
be familiar was an air emissions
facility so they coded textiles with uh
pfas containing chemicals and those
textiles as part of the process went
through a series of vertical dryers and
the the pfas containing dispersion was
essentially evaporated off dried off and
pfas was emitted from the facilities
stacks and transported through the air
deposited on the ground in several
surrounding communities where
groundwater contamination ensued so this
was first discovered in 2016 when the
facility sampled tap water that was
provided by the Merrimack Village
district and it was recognized that the
tap water was contaminated and it
started a huge investigation
so where we are today is that
um cincobain has installed air emission
controls it was required by a change of
law in our air Resources Division
oversaw the permitting of that uh
emission control which essentially
um is a what is called a regenerative
thermal oxidizer so they take natural
gas heat up a chamber put the pfas air
emissions through this chamber and
effectively break the carbon fluorine
bonds so that the emissions comply with
the permit
in terms of the groundwater
investigation cincobain was required to
investigate the area within what we call
the consent decree there was a 2018
consent decree between the state of New
Hampshire and cincobain and this area
was was part of that definition it's
approximately 64 square miles involving
five or six towns and uh
syncopene has been investigating a des
request groundwater quality within this
area and in 2019 the standard for pfoa
which is the primary contaminant from
Saint Cobain that we're finding in
groundwater that standard was lowered
from 70 parts per trillion to 19 to 12
parts per trillion which greatly
expanded the area under investigation
because the 70 part petroleum area had
frankly been pretty well characterized
prior to 2019 but with that lowering the
standard that an investigation expanded
outward
and currently cincobain is now in the
phase of um beginning to implement
permanent remedies so when they would
identify a property over standard they
would provide bottled water and
unfortunately people have been on
bottled water for um in some cases since
2019 so some residents been on for
several years and uh
we're now at the point where they're
beginning to install point of entry
treatment systems for some residents and
they're evaluating water lines and
designing water lines for certain areas
where water line feasibility is uh is an
option
is there a component of your question
yeah that just that just makes me angry
that's just all I mean literally those
people three years I mean and we're just
going to let them continue to operate
bottled water I mean it's not just
bottled water it's it's exactly what
you're in the shower and all of that
you're I mean you're contaminated from
all of those things and I just I can't I
just know from my friend that lives in
Litchfield because this is Litchfield
this is Bedford this is Merrimack this
is Hudson I mean all of these towns
I just don't understand a multi-billion
dollar million dollar company that's
continuing to be a polluter and we've on
our watch have just let that happen
you know unfortunately this has turned
into a bit of a legal uh issue so Des
has had to work with uh doj uh to enter
into legal negotiations on many aspects
of this
um and you know it's taken taken longer
thank you I'm gonna have to leave that
here because we have yet to hear from
Department of Health and Human Services
so um thank you very much for coming in
and uh and giving your presentation we
appreciate your time thank much and
please don't hesitate to contact me
director wimsat or any of the folks you
met today with any questions you have
foreign
with that I'd like to uh
see Colleen Smith from Department of
Health and Human Services food safety
division
foreign
good afternoon go right ahead I also
have paper copies of the presentation
did you want me to distribute we can
no worries um for the record my name is
Colleen Smith I'm the administrator for
the food protection section within the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I'm happy to be joined by Chuck
Metcalf who's graciously handing out the
presentation
um in the slot the paper format for
those that wish to follow along that way
and Chuck is a tremendous resource he
can answer any questions regarded to
Dairy plants and dairy farms he's been
with our department for 35 years so has
not only current knowledge about the
dairy program but a lot of historical
so thank you for allowing me the
opportunity to talk about the food
protection section within the Department
of Health and Human Services our mission
is to protect the Safety and Security of
the food supply in New Hampshire and we
take this role very very seriously we
know not only are we protecting the food
supply of New Hampshire residents but we
also know how important the food
industry is to our tourists that visit
the state so we are are inspecting not
only restaurants but also food that
you'll find in grocery stores are dairy
plants and we also have a shellfish
program which I'll talk more in detail
about
um as I mentioned we have four sub
programs within the food Protection
Program we have 20 employees total and
this is a photo of our of our group they
have a lot of responsibility we have as
I mentioned before our Dairy program a
beverage and bottled water program in
our food sanitation program which you'll
know as probably the any food that's
served immediately to Consumer at either
at a grocery store a deli a restaurant
or also food that's manufactured food
and then finally our molluscan shellfish
program
I'll first talk about our food
sanitation program that's our largest
program we have nine and a half
employees and when I say a half a time
employee we have a we have two part-time
employees and we also have staff that
are split between multiple programs
they inspect grocery stores schools
restaurants Mobile Food units or food
trucks which have been growing in
popularity over the last 10 years
definitely we inspect food manufacturers
and that could be anything from a large
company producing food we have several
of those in the state but it also could
be very home could be home-based food
producers or those making Jam jams or
jellies or pickles or relishes in a
commercial kitchen so really runs the
gamut between a million dollar companies
to to very small producers
um bed and breakfast facilities bakeries
and bars and lounges all fall within
our food inspectors they may have as
many as 600 to 700 establishments under
their purview we split the state
regionally they're inspected every 12
months or three years based on risk and
when we look at doing risk-based
inspections that means those that have
more of a complex menu are inspected
more frequently than maybe a store that
only is selling milk and eggs so that
that would be a type of establishment
that would get inspected every three
years but your full service restaurants
those have a higher frequency of
inspection
and this is a map to show how our food
inspectors are dispersed they they're
based out of their homes so they they
travel to their inspection District
based on where they live it's a little
bit hard to read on this map but those
cities and towns that are identified in
white we have 15 of them they're what
are called self-inspecting cities and
towns and that means the local Health
officer has responsibility for doing the
so that's an example of what's not under
the jurisdiction of our section and I'll
be honest with you the the food the food
responsibilities are very complex in the
state as I mentioned we have
self-inspecting cities and towns some we
do not at the state level uh inspect
temporary food establishments so these
would be food establishments that would
be serving food at for instance the New
Hampshire Motor Speedway as a part of
the the race there
with one caveat we do do voluntary
inspections of those those pictures
actually the picture on this slide is
actually one of our inspectors doing
those Inspections just to make sure
everything is in order but we don't
license those types of facilities that
are exempt from our license but there
are some high profile events such as New
Hampshire Motor Speedway that we do do
inspections of just because of the sheer
volume of folks that they they serve in
those events but they don't they're not
required to be licensed that would also
mean um like your Deerfield Fair those
the event the food trucks or food
establishments at that those venues
they're exempt from our licensing and
inspection
occasional Food Service establishments
and what that is is any establishment
that's operating four days or less in a
30-day period so that would be things
like a church breakfast those because
they're only operating once a week
they're exempt from our licensing and
inspection
our food pantries and soup kitchens are
also exempt by Statute from from our
license and inspection and then Child
Care Centers use camps and nursing homes
they're inspected by other agencies so
they're not inspected by by food
protection
and then to make things even more
complicated we have certain Commodities
which are regulated by the Department of
Agriculture and that would be eggs maple
syrup honey pet food and produce a
product that might have have maple syrup
as an ingredient that would fall to us
but just pure maple syrup that falls to
our one of our other programs is our
beverage and bottled water program so
any in-state manufacturers of bottled
water or or soda or other other
beverages they're part of this program
we also register any out-of-state
manufacturers of beverages in bottled
water and one recent change in our
regulation was
requiring bottled water manufacturers to
adhere to the same drinking water
standards in our state so the pfas
requirements that are for New Hampshire
drinking water they also now apply to
any bottled water shipping to our state
so we as part of their annual
registration were asking for testing
documentation to be sent to us so that's
a an above and beyond the federal
regular regulations of bottled water
standards
our Dairy sanitation program so this is
a FDA Cooperative program
and what that means is that any plants
are farms that are shipping milk
products a grade A milk products or milk
across state lines they're required to
be a part of this program and FDA gives
the state no money but they have
oversight over this program and that
it's basically to ensure that all states
are regulating milk and milk products to
the same level our inspectors have to be
certified by FDA to do these inspections
FDA requires us to inspect the
facilities at certain frequencies
which when they audit us to make sure
that we are compliant any if and it's
something that we have very very have to
take Monitor and keep very close
compliance because any violations of our
program could be detrimental to
um to our licensees who want to ship
product across the state we have 90
farms and it's Chuck Metcalf who I
introduced earlier he was showing me
data about the number of farms that have
changed are our profile and dairy farms
how that has changed over the last 50
years we have actually this number just
dropped from the time I made this slide
it's now 89 we have 89 goat cow or sheep
milk producing farms and 64 processing
plants
Although our processing plant numbers
have have shifted to the upward our
Farms have decreased over the last
several years
so we inspect Dairy Farms Dairy plants
the milk collars those that are driving
the milk trucks milk plants those that
are sampling milk at the plant level and
the dairy pasteurizers and they also our
Dairy inspectors are also required to
take water and milk products milk
samples at the farm in our lab Public
Health lab does that testing over a
our shellfish program so this is another
one of those FDA Cooperative programs
where any of our molluscan shellfish
dealers or Harvesters that want to
engage in interstate commerce they um
they have to be listed with the FDA and
it's another one FDA provides us no
resources but we're required to
administer the program to their
standards to allow our industry to be
able to ship across state lines this the
aquaculture industry has experienced a
tremendous amount of growth in the last
10 years we had one Harvester licensed
in 2012 and now we have 16. so that um
that it's it's definitely an industry
which has seen a lot of positive growth
and it's caught we basically have had to
shift some resp of our staff resources
again because we there there has a
there's a lot of inspection frequency
monitoring that FDA has over this
program
uh we also respond to food emergencies
that impact food establishment so this
could be power power outages fires
floods accidental or deliberate
contamination of food outbreaks or we
are we have a relationship that you know
should there we are we do exercises in
case there was a an event associated
with the Seabrook power plant to what
would happen to our food supply so those
um certainly we don't we we work hard at
preventing this through our licensing
inspection process but in the event of a
foodborne outbreak associated with a
food establishment we have the the
environmental health assessment role to
try to figure out the root cause of that
any foodborne outbreaks associated with
our food establishments
and then sure certainly if there's
something that's in Commerce to make
sure that product is effectively removed
along those lines if there are we
monitor FDA and USDA recalls and if we
find that there's any products shipped
to New Hampshire we are trying to get
those distrib distribution lists and
making sure that the stores have removed
those products from the shelves
and we also um we also accept consumer
complaints we handle probably on average
about a 300 consumer complaints a year
people either thinking that they became
ill from what they ate or we take many
sanitation complaints they you know
observed
poor Behavior poor sanitation behaviors
and then finally I just want to
highlight our our new redesigned website
we have tried to make it more
user-friendly knowing that our food
regulations are very complex we've spent
a lot of time trying to make things
easier for folks to follow and get the
answers to their questions and so I just
wanted to highlight that that there's
that information and we've also worked
on some food safety training videos in
the the last year or two hopefully make
things easier and help folks navigate
the not only the licensing process but
also giving some coaching on food safety
behaviors
and that um that this is this is my
contact information I'm happy to answer
any questions that you may have
no flurry of hands okay uh
representative Bixby please
yes so a couple a couple terms ago I
think it started uh we uh had a mushroom
harvesting Bill come through this
committee and uh I believe it actually
went finally made it through gel car in
July and I was wondering if the classes
are now available for mushroom
Harvesters great great question so we
have we have done
um the the answer your question is no
the class is not available I have been
trying very very very working very very
hard to try to get that up up and
running that wasn't our responsibility
to get the class up and running but we
had some key stakeholders that were a
part of the legislation process that had
offered to work on putting that class
together
um we I'm it's one of my uh to do class
things in the next few months especially
the the time for harvesting mushrooms
right now is not so great so we're
trying to get that stood up before the
for the springtime so that those that
are looking to harvest mushrooms we do
have the the rural infrastructure all
set we have the application ready to go
it's just we need that course and if I
can't get that our resources in state to
um get help us get this up and running
there are possibilities from either New
York or Rhode Island that we can tap
into to help hopefully get this stood up
thank you
for the questions of Representative
Murray
hi it's nice to
nice um thanks for taking my question so
one question I did have was around
aquaculture and your oversight over it
whether it's just regarding molluscum or
if it's an integrated aquaculture and
it's dealing with things like seaweeds
and Kelps is that also something your
heart harvesting of those types of
things where does that fall
so we don't we don't have anyone
currently we've had we don't have any
concurrently harvesting seaweed or kelp
for for food we have had some interest
in doing that I don't I think it was
they were looking at other applications
like cosmetics and maybe even like a
brewery that was looking into it but
currently it's it's it and if we were to
have seaweed or calpe would fall more
into our food program versus that
aquaculture that's purely molluscan
shellfish
any other questions representative
pecenza
so just a quick question I think it was
about three years ago or so it was um a
very well-known 100 year old restaurant
in New Hampshire and they had like a
foodborne illness that actually caused a
death through their
um
it wasn't in the restaurant it was like
in their banquet portion
the back room the Puritan I'm sure so is
that does that get reported to you guys
or how does I was just wondering so
so yes we weren't directly involved in
that investigation because it happened
in one of the the self-inspecting cities
so when a a foodborne outbreak happens
they take the lead in that instance we
support them certainly our Infectious
Disease Control folks those that are
doing the disease surveillance and our
nurses were more directly involved than
than our section but it was the man was
Manchester and that's took the lead on
doing that environmental investigation
okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none I want to thank you so very
much for joining us this afternoon and
uh giving us a presentation of your
department
thank you thank you looking forward to
so it's uh been a long day and I
appreciate everybody's attention I hope
that you learned something today I hope
that you were uh
interesting given some interesting
information tidbits of from all our
department heads and also from this
morning's presentation about how our
committee
we'll be working
and I look forward to working to all
with all of you together
um
we have um
put together a hearing schedule for next
Tuesday beginning at 10 A.M
look forward and look to your emails
you'll see the uh the announcements have
gone out already so please put those on
your calendar and I look forward to
seeing you next week
foreign